this is jocko podcast number 258
with me jocko willink
several ak-47s opened fire before the
king bees wheels touched down
nonetheless black and the remaining
three vietnamese st
alabama team members exited the h-34
as the king bee lifted off the nva
gunfire increased significantly and
moments later
the laboring sikorsky h-34 crashed
although this was black's first sog
mission into prairie fire
he knew the odds were stacked against st
alabama
he and cowboy argued vigorously for an
immediate extraction
the team had been compromised the
element of surprise was gone
the other american who had not gone
through special forces qualification
course at
fort bragg remained silent no
said the new one zero i'm an american no
slant-eyed son of a [ __ ] is going to
run me off
watkins offered the 1-0 a chance to
extract
the offer was declined the team was to
continue
the team leader ordered the point man to
walk down a well-traveled trail away
from the lz into the jungle
black cowboy and the point man hoa
argued against heading down the trail
the first rule of recon was to never use
trails especially well-traveled ones
the 1-0 pulled rank and ordered the team
to move down the trail
with hoa leading the way and the elder
green beret following a short distance
behind him
the trail wound into the jungle and
curved to the left
st alabama moved cautiously as the team
went down the trail
it moved parallel to a small rise on its
right that was about 10 to 20 feet
above the team on it the nva colonel
had quickly assembled the force of 50
nva soldiers
who set up a classic l-shaped ambush
the quiet of the early morning jungle
was shattered when the nva troops opened
fire with their ak-47s and sks rifles
the ak rounds ripped into the point
man's chest and face
the fatal impact of those rounds lifted
the canteen covers around his waist
appearing to keep his body suspended in
here in air
what had been a human body milliseconds
earlier
was being chewed into an amorphous
form that hit the ground with a
sickening thud
arterial blood spurted high into the air
three rounds slammed into the one zero's
head
blowing off the right side of his face
killing him instantly
nothing could prepare st alabama for the
grisly horror unfolding at that moment
the one one buried his face in the dirt
and started praying
black and the remaining st alabama team
members returned fire
the green beret stood there firing us on
single shot
picking off nva soldiers on top of the
rise he loaded his car 15 and went down
the line
shooting them one after another
sometimes they spun and he shot them a
second or third time
as the nva continued to fire on the team
black and cowboy formed the team into a
circle and directed a barrage of m-79
grenade rounds
and car 15 fire into the surrounding
jungle
then startling eerie silence
black thought he was in his grave st
alabama was lo
in a low spot with the ground rising 10
to 20 feet
on both left and right both the nva and
st alabama
tended to their wounded while the living
combatants slammed loaded magazines into
their hot weapons
there was moaning and groaning human
suffering on both sides
black got on the prc 25 to tell covey
about
st alabama's tragic turn of events black
and tho
scavenged weapons and ammo from the dead
st alabama team members
fortunately covey was still airborne
black reported that he had two kias and
two wias
and was surrounded by nva troops
covey responded you're not a doctor nor
for that fact a medic
you can't determine who's dead or alive
bring out all bodies for verification of
death
then more than 100 nva regulars
opened fire on st alabama as enemy
troops had reinforced the initial ambush
unit
by now the nva were two rows deep the
front row fired ak-47s
the second row threw grenades or fired
rpgs
now that is a story from
the book across the fence by john
striker meyer also known as
tilt it's a story of october 5th
1968 a special forces sog mission
over the border into laos the story is
also covered in the book whiskey tango
foxtrot which is by
lynn black code named black jack
and for a variety of reasons
lin was not able to join us on the show
but through tilt and his
friends in the special operations
community
we are absolutely honored to have with
us tonight
khan cowboy doane a vietnamese soldier
that fought for freedom alongside
american special forces soldiers
from sog khan thank you for joining us
it's an honor to have you here
my places and also joining us
once again is john striker meyer the man
himself tilt a special forces
soldier member of sog who has been on
the podcast before
180 181 182 186 247
and 248. good to be back sir good to be
here with cowboy
thank you con it's uh it's it's awesome
to have you here
and um so your nickname is cowboy how do
we get the nickname cowboy
okay one mission i have a code name
for radio contact they put me named
cowboy and then
a lot of guys going i still survival
so my man and my american man
call me cowboy from them it's a good
name
we always called him that in camp nobody
called him connor was like hey cowboy we
knew who cowboy was
they can't they're a little bit diff
difficult to
pronunciation or by american
so it's easy or you know
like the for friendly say hey cowboy
at all the time even my uh
commanding officer bill cellon
or major snail right because
when we got information every single
morning call me cowboy
everybody know who who i was
and well that's awesome before you
became cowboy what let's go back to your
uh
you know where you're from where you
grew up what that what that was like a
lot of a lot of americans we don't know
what that's like
growing up in in vietnam so what what
year were you born
i was born from north vietnam
they need been providing
and then i was very young
i don't know anything but 1954
my family moved to the south in order
the communists took over north vietnam
we immigrated to the south and we living
in saigon
for two years my family
moved up to dallas city you know that
acted
uh high central they're very nice
city beautiful beautiful and
the weather it like it the just normal
and you can see the you can see it a lot
like the young lady like
19 or 20 years old you like it
so we're living there what was it like
when before you left what was it like
when the communists came and took over
yeah oh with the knob yeah what was that
like for your family what did it
what did they do what did that seem like
what happened
i don't know because i was young but
i understand after that that the
communists want to kill
everybody and they want to collect you
know property from
their citizens to build you know
look at the communist party
and that's why my farm my family
moved from north to the south
what was your father's job what did he
do
uh actually
i still now i still don't understand
what he did he only divided man
but he was in the business of business
vision of man
yes and he moved down to the show
he visioned it but inside you
you know the uh the back rice
the gun in there but i don't know who
who he was
okay and sometimes he
be the taxi driver okay and
motorcycle driver to take care of
the people but i understand now i
understand
like a huge spike now he worked
under on the cover anywhere
anytime and
1963
no president northern jim
you know him he was assassinated before
kennedy
before kennedy yes and i i i
strongly believe that he worked with him
and after
revolution revolution from the
from the vietnamese army
they put my father in jail
because he worked for the old government
he worked for the president
jim that time i went
like at the
12 years old or 13 years old
i still don't understand it
but when i visit him the time he was in
jail
i learned something i learned something
about him
and
i'm thinking about you know what i'm
trying to do
to pay back the people
you know did to my father
[Music]
and then in jail
but he very smart man he told me
american gallant go to vietnam
when i was young i studied french
and then when he in jail he said hey i
better learn
english because you understand americans
gotta come to vietnam
and study i i'm studying english
at the time lucky for me
it my family very close to you know
the music i mean vietnamese american
association
so i study from them
and then my father's still in jail
[Music]
and my family you know the economic it
going down a lot
so i try to survive by myself
and for my family and i'm very lucky
when i study english my teacher
he's american
he understand my situation and my family
and he advised me
to join to the army
and i but i be i i don't know about him
too
but he's very nice guy
uh-huh meaning you don't know what his
actual job was
he only teacher just a teacher you're
the teacher
but i talk in my mind he wants
to do extra work for the government
sometimes yeah yeah
yes he gotta go you know to
pick up the who's the bad guy or who's
the good guy
because in the class he had he already
all the time asked where where your
family
what husband you know our situation my
family
about the money but you know how do we
survive
he he learned from us a lot from the
student
and i believe you know after that he
picked up
the student to become you know the the
employee for the us government
that's what i talked right now uh so he
was
a recruiter looking for good people that
will do a good job
fighting for people and good man
or do something or smack man
that way i'm talking about my teacher
so when you when he told you to join the
army how did you feel about that idea
oh he showed me the uh
the movie pt
109 yeah about jfk yes yes
okay and in the class you know he saw
the movie
he said you want to be john f kennedy i
said why not
and and not only one time he asked me he
asked me a lot
and he know
something going on to the to my family
and he can read what are gonna do it
say just join to the army but i say
i don't know anything about it that's
what he told
and he called my friend another friend
say
take him to the joint with the special
force
i said what they have to special for
the people crazy because the vietnam war
we understand situation like you know
now the marine or you know
coast guard you know like infantry you
like it
airborne so you know who's the one which
one the hero
and i don't know anything about it
say try it try it
and they written letter to saigon to
pasta to uh to shock
headquarters yeah
yes and i say yeah i i i go
so how old were you at this time at
17 17
yeah and what year was it uh 1966.
so 1966 you're 17 years old
and you send or they send a letter to
sag telling that they've got a good
recruit he speaks english and as a hot
commodity we need a good english
speakers
interpreters did you have any idea what
you were getting into
no no no
i don't know but you know when we were
young
we're going to be hero we're going to be
you know like it
stronger more than another one like so i
just
enjoy it like jfk yeah john f
kennedy can do everything you see
during at the time you know from this
one he swim
oh you're another iceland i love you
save this man
yeah took his man in saved him handsome
guy
yes he i like him very much
so that's why i'm joined
so what was your view of america at that
time you must have had a pretty positive
view of america you knew you were going
to
join the army and you were going to
support the american efforts there
i don't pay attention anything i just
want to join
and join do it whatever they need to me
to do it
and he's you know the my man
actually you know my on behalf of my
father
you know most of known like a ton right
everybody in my village i mean the
county
these are we're talking about the nungs
the chinese so they know who i was
they know who am i so they work together
we work together at all the time
in the camp so that's why i can go with
the
frenchman team right on virginia i go
with the rose island team
i will go with the mississippi team i'll
ask it before it becomes alaska
i go anywhere because they say hey
cabo you're good man we need to learn
from him
so that's why you know i like to go with
it with them
because unbehaved you know the attitude
my farm my family and my father
to their family so we work together
a lot of time even one day i get you
know
vacation i went on vacation you say hey
cowboy
tomorrow i gotta go you gotta go with me
i said yes
i do and then i quit my vacation
i go with the team so to
training each other to learning from
each other i'm not saying you know i'm
good man
but my experience when i was young
i'm in younger with my family we work
farmer so i'm you know
strong looks skinny but strong right and
sometimes sometimes you know i'm i'm
thought
we got to do it we got to do it you can
see it my hand here
scar it i can cut the bullet
[Music]
in my body but i still survival
and i'll tell you you're lucky you were
skinny because if you were any bigger
those bullets would it
would have hit worse spots you were hard
to shoot at
yeah you're right not big like a human
when
i saw him the first i saw down to him
he said hey this guy's too big and he
footed it longer
that's what sal said yeah and normally
american the big guy like you and like
him but you know when we're there we're
very skinny
and a small one like 120 pound
or 100 tap pow you know
look look at hey there's a baby shine
right right
that american call my people that baby
little people yeah little people yeah
affectionate term
yeah yeah and but you grew up in the
jungle
so for you being in the jungle was just
just normal that's just
yes yes you're used to you're just
that's the way you lived that's the way
you grew up
so that's a real advantage yes online he
spoke english
unlike the round eye over here you're
not the city slicker
i can i can honor to tell you
we can smell this this smell
because when we go land down the jungle
mm-hmm
they got a flower right they gotta plant
the rice
or they gotta plant unkind thing in the
jungle
we know we can imagine
say what they gonna do where the
they live and where their postcard
where the hospital and we
we can smell it and then
my citizen can understand
how communist activity there
they can grow up they can do anything
become
greek with local people right that's why
the green berets
love our indigenous people yeah the
nungs
like he said he could smell they had the
extra sense that we never had
particularly somebody like me a city
slicker
that's why people like him are number
one and they kept
us alive mm-hmm in the jungle we
we yielded to them they always ran point
not us
and they got because we local local
local people there
and we can smell different look at the
bird
white white or chicken
we we can comparation right away
inside the jungle if you see it quiet
that means nobody moved right that's a
problem
is that a problem trouble is close we
understand exactly all right
i always say hey keep your [ __ ] hand
down i'm sorry
yeah sometimes people need to keep their
[ __ ] heads down
that's the [ __ ] truth but it true
i'm not telling you a liar you know yes
and then
what was the training like that you went
through to get you ready
to work with the special forces team did
you go into the regular army did they
process you into the regular army or did
they just take you up to
one of the one of this one of the ccn or
something cam duck which was
you first that was the first uh sog
training base was up by core
and cam duck was open had bad weather
but that's where they did the
natural training very close to the
border
how long did they train you for
long time even now
when they send you there you're free to
do
it mean not in the law not in the
morning wake up
six o'clock whatever they needed
to train it they could call you one or
two
p a.m or one 1 82 p.m
and they let you free and then
tomorrow we got to go range arrange many
times
and then what what do you think when we
you got young the first time that you
carry a gun
we got a like a tan you know boxed off
the bullet
right we go there we shoot it free
mm-hmm only my friends say hey how to
where to work weapon how to work the
weapon and then
next day we got to go ranger to fire
how to clean the weapon and yes would
you were you carrying an ak or you
carrying a
car 15. okay the first thing when i
joined
what uh enjoy it enjoying that
only carbine okay and then later
carbine m1 and m2
and then after that they change to
uh squid and k swedish
swedish k right squid and k and then
stan
oh the stand stand gonna have both
standard xilan
you know yeah the magazine on the side
yes okay and later on we moved to the
fubai we used m16
ar-15 and then the car 15. and then
m16 and then car 15.
because they're hard to come by but we
we're training
every weapon like a motor
82 60 put on you know right here in the
leg
yeah to punch to the enemy
sure we take home kind of weapon or b40
m72 and and with these special forces
american special forces soldiers that
you guys were in charge or some group
was in charge of training
yes that was the com at cam duck it was
the first camp
so so many early saw guys were there and
that was part of the recruitment that
came through saigon
and that's why cowboy ended up there and
it was training and plus
the camp was so close to the border you
had self-defense at night yes
there would be there would be pods and
the nva attacked the camp several times
prior to may 68 when the camp got
overrun
and it was a there's a whole book about
that called bait
and uh after that they closed camp dock
he
and by that time alabama was already at
fob1
when they closed we
i get there in may of 68 late in may
mcintyre and these guys came in
with his team and of course you want to
tell them about alaska
ah that's great yeah what happened with
uh st alaska
they blow out everybody was killed
separated one zero
john allen who escaped and he came he
need for two days and he caught and he
won the helicopter palace brought him
back and he said
we want to change the name of the team
they changed it from alaska
to alabama and then tim schaaf was the
one zero
when they were training john allen first
davis
dave i forgot about david john allen
and then uh team shop
and then and then we went close
everyone closed yeah later we we got to
go
fob no
ccn but that was you have to be closed
for b1 but this is like
may with a very incremental month so is
that was that where you first checked in
you went to
you went to alaska or had alaska just
become alabama
yes the first the first the only reason
why you didn't go on the mission he had
just turned and missed a mission or he
would have been on that mission with
alaska
right no i i'm from the h hatcher fox
oh that's right i forgot i'm sorry okay
so you started with the hatchet
force yeah headshot we worked you know
like at the platoon or a company
to go with after he even got a contact
to the enemy
and the people from the uh from the
recon
go down to the hearts of looking who's
the bad who's the good
and they say hey cowboy you want to be
uh recon team i say
why not i try my best yeah and
the first thing i came to the uh to the
team
recon team i scanned everybody
looking you know bad guy look
because he the nuns are taller than the
other vietnamese on the team
and people say hell okay try
try your best and then i joined the team
at the time at the time of that our last
guy is burnt out
they didn't blow out and when i joined
it
they gotta rebuild the team and they say
hey alaska
is no good too many goals because too
many
people die so we need to change the name
and change to alabama
and then we work with the alabama
until after we went close
we came to the now in sicien
said in sicily and they got an alabama
team there too
so my name was chang to indiana
that was early after they closed f4b1
and uh tilt was telling me about one
time when you were getting taken out on
strings
and somehow you ended up upside down or
something like that yeah
that's normal thing but ah
i remember we had a contact with the
enemy
but we cannot move out here to the
to the to the
our lg we inside the jungle
and then the chopper
came in throw down the rope
one of each we got a drop different rope
but tariko for
for shape for the team
four guys come up pick up the uh
the drop to hang it up and another four
guys still
you know keep them accepted right
security
keep shooting security and then after
the chopper lap pull out the
fall guy we came over
and then another fought up but
throw it down we tried to hook it up
but i john allen another two
vietnamese guy hooked up the rope when i
turn over you know i try to hook
hook myself into my route
but i look it up you know the tree here
the rope would turn over
oh the tree so what happened
what are you gonna do i saw i said hey
helen look it up
and then you know we we got a stable
wreck we don't have a stable recognition
that's a swiss c
yeah we have a three row two one four
seat and one for here and
another two for sid right and john allen
saw it he gave me one from him
oh if i hook it up there
and at the top we're gonna cut it out
and i drop it back
to the to the plan i gotta die
and then they they put up
i only one string in here
wow you know the d with the d ring
holding you in
yeah in here and when they're going up
like at the thousand feet or two
thousand fish something
and then i got a roof shop here i got a
gun i got us
you know the uh my weapon here yes
and then it going down turn over to here
to my knee
you're upside down there upside down i
know that feeling
and then john evelyn wanted to warp it
but but the wind
cannot be together at the time
so when i rub it it's going down to
to my mind to your feet down here yeah
yes
but luckily we got a jungle boat
you know the uh to form the jungle boat
yes
it's still tight here and i all the way
down
so you were hanging on the rope by just
your ankle and your jungle boot his
jungle boot
yeah and then
john allen stood up
because we got a flag and right we would
shoot flagon
yes and you know the the chop would
still flow
and we here we understand that we we
we we thought you know they might not
might not know
something uh you know you're upside down
yes
yes so so john allen was shooting the
flare gun to try and get the
helicopter pilots to realize what was
happening to looking down but
the communist underground so how do we
do
you know it flows still flow through
flow
and then my my body is up and down
and until we glow to the fubar
and the chopper drop out now
when when i lie down on the ground
i still understand
i'm looking down there in my gun that
magazine did empty
i chain the magazine lock and low again
and do it
and then the pilot coming down to pick
me up to the uh
put inside the chopper right
and i don't know anything anymore you're
unconscious
from there to the uh to the full body
johnson you know bruce johnson right yes
the medic at that time he was
unconscious and the medic
was bruce johnson on that mission or in
the helicopter
no he inside the cam okay
he he died and bruce how do you do his
elbow
in your chest the weight yeah is your
heart going but i still
i still know everything even i died
wow then bro johnson shoot the gun
hey medic and the car coming in
pick me up to the uh to the adv hospital
right and on the way
uh he he tried to you know wake me up
you use your elbow when i lie down here
punch in here you can see the bone
coming out right here
yeah bruce was a medic and so he died
three times and bruce told us about that
years later that's how he brought him
back to life
and they thought he was dead they took
him down to the field hospital right
there at fubai
say hey i beat you up you
you don't wake up you rather die buddy
you say i love you very much he loved me
very much
but i don't know anything but i remember
i
what he thought i remember who got it i
don't get the thing
but i cannot do anything
they mean i die for something
and then they brought me to the hospital
doctor said hey
can't do anything to me anymore
but i remember do you remember hearing
the doctor say that they can't help you
anymore
yes i still alive
even i don't do anything i can't do
anything
the people thought i'm i'm dead
but myself i still alive wow
i hear what you say i know something
going on knocked something
i live in there you feel bruised on your
chest yeah even
he beat my in my chest right here
okay you can see the bone here
there it is
the special forces medics men they're
relentless they'll do anything to keep
you alive
yes yes everything yeah the first thing
you put in here
wake up quiet but he almost cry i know
that
but i can't do anything
upside down a long time and then after
he
he tried to wake me up by this one
and then i will
see how big the bruise right yeah yeah
but he was in shape then after that
about two hour three hour i think three
hours
i forget three hours my team
came back club alcohol
and say hey cowboy good good good man
we gotta bring him back
drunk uh john
allen yeah john helen uh
ken crowley took of the ship right
drew up to the hospital pointed a gun to
the doctor
saying you better take care of him or
are you gonna
you die so so john allen went to the
doctor
and brought a gun and said you either
take care of our boy cowboy
sometimes the doctors the american
doctors there were reluctant
john walton did that had the same
problem after his mission in august
and with cowboy they heard they weren't
getting the right treatment
the 1-0 went right down there and they
addressed the doctor and
because they had a policy no indigenous
people at the hospital
oh okay and that's what they were up
against and our team leaders
had to get a little aggressive how did
it solve that problem
well in this case it was a car 15. yeah
we got
yeah who got the king yeah with john
wall he just threatened to beat him okay
you mp right now right
in the front of my chest clean my mind
carl 15 and ganette yeah what do you
think
what will you do yeah i'm gonna do
whatever you want me to do actually
they they come up to you they are saying
you better take care of cowboys
and my friend you know the people drunk
crying miss me
i knew i hear that but i can't do
anything
and mario give me a coffee you give me
smoke
and i don't know maybe they put the hot
water in
into my mouth and i feel something go
through here
and then i wake up say hey
what the hell going on here where's the
party
and later our
we come back to camp
this is all before october 5th yeah yeah
did you
now did you did i hear right that you
had a relative
that was also uh yeah well his wife's
brother was on st idaho when idaho got
wiped out in may
of 68. that was your wife's brother's
brother
brother yes i have a tube rounder one of
the
uh got the bioreplica at the language
and another one with the idaho team
elaine bay was the a camp that got
overrun on tet
when he had the nva tank and they
captured some of our people
as well some of the indigenous people
that took him back to pows
family paid a high price jeez
jeez how often
so now it's 19 how long were you in the
job for
the total line that from 66 to 72
i mean 66 to middle up to
67 the timer is for training
in 67 i'm joined to the alabama team
due to august 72
i lost my leg
wow and so these so these guys you're
going out the whole time you're just
going out on mission
mission mission mission yes no
i mean other way maybe you go back to
town get a little break for
a week or something a month but most of
the time it's just work
yes sometimes you know like the
yes i just call it a button for
one mission total time
sometime only 10 days sometimes one
month
three times so that's why
we receive the money get paid
for two time or three times okay for
example
on the first day of the month we take a
money
we go downtown for two three days
and after through three days we have no
more money left
mission many mission mission i say okay
we go
and we stand by there for a week
because the weather or whatever you know
some reason we we can not go
and then we went there but you know the
you know the shock glow right it
when we come up to the lc the community
stood up
we we came back we're not jumping down
and then after a few day
one zero we gotta pass go past
he say okay for one day and you know i
tried to do it he understand it
no money
he took to the s1 to get the money
and then we on uh we on pass for today
or whatever we can we came back
because the reason we stand by for that
target
we cannot go you know the long trip like
you go saigon or
a lot just go away yes and then
come back for the mission again
we come up there because the weather or
what
whatever for after a week we cannot go
at the weekend i say that's why it's
october 5th
beginning of the month they got through
the pay day and the weather broke
because we'd had rains and months some
at the end of the monsoon season we
stand by
for for the target for like two weeks
three weeks or one month
a lot of reason we cannot go there
weather or the accommodate
activity on the ground i i bet
you know like at the when we went out
the mission
everybody know even the pentagon or even
you know that the
headquarter asia headquarters in saigon
then the white house
or whatever we have attached to the
warehouse we work
together i think so so that's why
but we can't i cannot remember how many
mission i gotta go i cannot remember
too many because you're busy yes you
didn't write a diary you couldn't write
a diary no
no we can't do anything we can we
we can say hey i go there i go there i
go there but
when we received the mission like
the 1-0 say hey we gotta go outside
we understand ourselves we gotta go dmv
we know the dmv we gotta go
uh lao we know
we gotta go cambodia thailand
and vietnam the border we know situation
from them because we learn from
from training from the north move to the
south
they got so many secret joan
from the from the communists
and we know when they move from the
north to
from the north to the south how they
working on it how people wear it
too heavy like a root shock
like a web gear who got it like a
hundred pound
or more another towel right some of this
yes
close to it yes but the communists
they don't wear anything yes ak-47 and
akfest
because they live in there they don't
need food
they don't need carrying water they
don't need kind of food with them
because they live in there like in my
house
we came down there we carried in the
heavy
then we learn from them we know
how their activity
but our job it protect this guy
he he told big
and you know we we're easy to move
and we easy to understand them but he
from here
he came to vietnam
into younger he can't do anything
young and dumb but
you know they're good
good morning else so uh they smile
more than else we learn from the
vietnamese
so on this mission on october 5th
the the helicopter puts you guys on the
ground you're getting shot at
before you land one of the helicopters
then
gets shot up and crashes
and and the 1-0 says we're still going
correct uh yes
okay when when we came down the first
chopper
we made me james strong
and another two even another two
vietnamese we got to go night guy
we came down the communist way
we dropped out the ground
they shoot it up
and we're not surprised about it
because we understand situations did you
see the flag that was flying
yeah the nba flag nba flag oh there's an
nva flag
yeah that has to be a little bit of a
warning sign that's why lynn
argued with the one zero saying that
flag is just at least three thousand
people here and we're nine
like yeah look at the uh the flag
according from the flag we can make it
out like the
not division like it regime like a three
thousand guy in the on the ground
we understand that in three thousand
puku
we understand boku yeah
then lynn black tried to get down they
got shot
then king b lip up and another king bait
they got a tactical
from the chopper they land this way down
this way land this way down this way and
shoot another
place to make it difficult to
for communist adjustment where we're
going down right
and then another chopper that means it's
dirty for it burnt out drop it out
crash that's crushed
but you know we have on the ground
help up the chopper what you gonna do
we gotta go and the lim black drop down
when we dropped out you know that the
plan
lg we gotta move to the jungle right way
to hide and
and we got a very quick briefing
say what you got to do next
according from the pack working of the
uh
walkers was flying covey okay when they
did the insertion
and we got a briefing with them
the pack what can you say
if the team was and wanna attraction
you have a right to do it
but james try the big guy the one zero
said no
he said no he thought you know
well we're very strong but he he forgot
to understand that
not in there three thousand guys there
and not our homeland
that a communist land right there then
layoffs
yes and then they say
she continued march yeah that's what he
said
and then lynne black told me
let's go we should go back and he said
and then we go yeah that was the last
wrong decision he made in his life
yes and we move about like
like 15 feet
we saw you know the postcard from the
communists
then black forget to tell you we found
the ak-47
magazine really yeah and then we found
you know the rain course
was that right yeah from the uh from the
uh from the uh
from the communists yes and the tree
they let
they see that you know very clean
so i understand you know they're sitting
there watching yet they
sit there for the photograph from the
communist there's an lz
watch stand stan they had a lot of those
set up with different lz's that were
because there's only so many in layouts
at that point
so they had lz watchers and they had
some they were beginning to get
platforms and that's one of the first
ones
i forgot about yes but they had the
platform that's what he's talking about
they saw
so in addition they knew that they were
compromised by the gunfire
they saw the platform so he had to go
back and yet the one zero said go down
the trail
with a helmet uh communist uh
hat this helmet yes so
what was the one zeros background right
now like in this operation
he had come from germany so he's been
assigned to germany he has state side
duty
but he never been to vietnam so he was
not familiar with
working with our vietnamese counterparts
listening to people like cowboy
and listen to lynn lynn had a whole year
experience of combat
and so he was one of these old school
guys i'm the i'm the leader we're going
to do this
and that was the last bad decision he
made in his life
took the team into it and i still tell
him
and then we're not you know going out
the trail
we we go by indus jungle so
when you're down a trail that's a big
mistake
yes that never happened would you guys
ever have situations where
the team would look at the 1-0 and say
no we're not doing that
well that's what they had there and the
1-0 overruled them
and most of the times our we would
listen to our
our indigenous people our little people
if they said don't go to the reason
and uh that's just the mutual respect we
had for him
yeah um particularly once you're on the
ground
so it's just a matter of the rapport
between
this was a new team that come together
and they've just taken the experience
one zero off
who had combat experience he had many
missions
that tim schaaf was the one zero prior
because the other
person jim stride was more rank they
appointed him the team
and uh they told tim to give him another
team
yeah this is why when you're in a
leadership position you listen to people
as if you listen to your team i mean
correct
this is why there's nothing you if you
let your ego get in the way
and you say i'm gonna let these people
tell me what to do it's like okay
it doesn't work out well you gotta stay
humble as a leader
yeah any leadership class if you want to
show what you shouldn't do this is the
classic example
but uh we don't have a training with him
no no
oh and you never even trained with him
no no
yeah we're training yeah the
the uh the other uh ivan pass
right and then you're on the island with
tim shaw
they had that pre-training mission where
they're training for the mission
but the teachers with another
this is bad all the way across the board
and this is the one where the navy
saved yeah saved st alabama because they
were on this training mission and they
had
a lot of it's an area where you had viet
cong
and nva but thailand before thailand
yeah nva and so they they got into a
world of
trouble their world of [ __ ] with them on
the training mission and they drove
and the nba drove them down to the south
china sea
from their high ground because they had
higher ground drove them down
and lynn fortunately had a frequency for
the navy
and one of the navy not a pt boat but a
boat that had two
two or three fifty calibers on and they
came in and picked the team up
otherwise they would have been wiped out
right on a training mission
it's a rough training mission it was
cowboy wasn't happy about that either
no i like it because it's free you know
it can go yeah now
fishing let me uh let me pick this back
up from the book on this mission on on
october 4th so where we left off they're
sorry on on october 5th where this left
off was
the nva are two rows deep the front row
firing ak-47s the second row throwing
grenades
and and firing rpgs and then
i'm gonna pick this back up says another
vietnamese st alabama team member was
wounded
the team had to get out of the hole or
die in it the bold nva told the st
alabama members to chu hoy
or surrender speaking first in french
english and finally vietnamese
st alabama's weapons drowned out further
chu hoy requests
the 1-1 so they asked you to surrender
and you shot at him
and the chu hoy was a whole program
right it was a whole program to get
people to
switch sides right right we had a chuhoy
and then they knew the program
so they used the same word surrender and
st alabama and it answered it in fine
style
with the car one hand grenade one
magazine
that answered to them yes
uh then it says the one one continued to
pray
so the one one got he he kind of lost it
a little bit
totally and he was curled up in a ball
he was putting his face in the sand and
he was
trying to pray i can't tell
got it because he on my team got it he
was on my team
i need to protect him he need to protect
me yeah
he owned my team well it says here black
couldn't believe it
then black says this is no time to pray
do unto others before they do unto you
he yelled whether or not the nva
soldiers were praying they continued to
move around st alabama
some climbing into trees cowboy and
black crawled 15 feet toward them close
enough
so that cowboy heard the nva commander
tell his troops to prepare to charge
st alabama's position so
you actually heard their commander give
the order prepare to charge yes sir
the commander also told his troops on
the long side of the l ambush not to
fire
black quickly rigged a claymore mine in
the direction of the pending charge
the fearless nva mounted a charge toward
st alabama with ak-47s on full automatic
black detonated the claymore mine it
blew a huge hole in the nva ranks
before the smoke cleared st alabama ran
through the human
carnage firing car 15s on full automatic
and throwing
m26 frag grenades while dragging their
three wounded team members
miraculously st alabama made it through
the nva wave of attackers
and moved back towards the lz leaving
their dead behind
we tried to bring them up with us but we
could
i tried to move up to wrap the hand
the dead man ak-47
i gotta move back i'm planned by
going up you know the strike
hit the big guy too big you're the best
guy boom up
and i kind of climb over and when they
shoot it
hit to the dry body
and i can feeling his body shake
when he hit the bullet wow so you're
trying to drag his body and his body is
getting shot
yeah i understand exactly when
i told them my last but they never
listen he
he never listened to me even there i
heard
hey come in and say ambush
don't kill them doesn't mean don't kill
us oh because they wanted to capture you
they wanted caps
and then i do it a lot
so for those of you that are just
listening to this uh cowboy keeps giving
the hand signal for hey we need to
circle up and get out of here get get
the helicopters and get out of here
that's what you're giving the handshake
the get the king bees
up and then he never listened to me
i know he said go
he uh deployment the vietnamese team
leader here
and uh jim strike um
back up him and then
then black right another m79 here
he said go you know
you know you know the rule from the team
the first man get up
first step second step duck step
another man stand up okay and step two
to the boot where where the first man
stepped
and he stand up i saw i saw him because
i hate him i said he said no
a lot of time but he never listened to
me
and first step he going down second step
dog step i hear the bullet
and he down turn around
i'm not stay there for for save my life
i gotta turn around and then the victory
i lay there and it come and it shoot
again
because we're very close like here to
here what 10 feet
i don't know more than 10 feet wow
no more than 10 feet the bush
he live in there and then when i
try to move into gathered like at the
soa map and then
the the thing for survivor right in his
pocket
survivor radio and the radio director
again soi soi right yes
radio frequency i tried to count hold
everything in his body given to
lean even to black
and tried to take him out i said hey
struck straight strike if nothing
happened
what will you do i try to climb up
and they should be again i'm lucky
i'm very lucky because you know his body
is very big
when i try to move it especially the
deployment need too
so what what are we gonna do we can't do
anything
but when later on
the team letter in here the gun you know
point
like it to to his head but he that he
didn't see it
look here his head here the the
ak-47 gun right here
and the carmen is upright when he
shooted
we're gonna we're gonna find out where
he has
and then observe this and then say hey
ak 47 pointed a log here
anything and
hit hit you know the low right that
appointment
hit now going down here and he shoots a
comment it
dropped out the ak-47 here
so you never know it from here to here
how do we survival
and open in my mind we got it
training in it in in cam we say
one hanker net one magazine
doesn't mean you have a hand ganette
and you have a magazine
when we throw down hanging egg we cannot
throw it too far
we throw it down it means clear
communists
around us one hang on it one magazine
when we told the grenade to close we
upgrade
the communist pick up the grenade throw
it back
so that's why we got it one hanging it
one magazine and
we tried to get it and we got a single
shot
be sure to comment this keep that hat
down
they don't have a timer to looking to
pick up the grenade
you don't want to play catch with a hand
grenade i said one hang in
it one [ __ ] hang in it one [ __ ]
magazine
and when because we hey i drill in
in home right right and we talk in it
so that helped to get you guys out of
that hole then that's what he was
talking about at that point we don't
have
we the communists we have they don't
have a time or two
thinking what we gonna do
and then after my my get my magazine is
empty
he shoot it up ding ding ding how the
communists doing
nothing can't do anything and then
what we we clear around us
and another another wave one negative
one magazine
and then like a d we got a big company
because everybody want to throw the one
one hanger neck what do
what do you think what did you hear
so they scared us how we how we're
fighting
so that's why you know we try to clear
around us
and then we be shaped at the time
meanwhile going back to the book uh
covey says the king bees had to return
to fubai
to refuel no extraction was possible
for at least two to three hours
meanwhile the relentless and the
relentless and bloodied nva ran
after the spike team black planted a
claymore mine with a five second time
delay fuse it wreaked havoc on the hard
charging nva
at as the smoke cleared and the body
parts settled back to the earth
st alabama split in half again and
charged through the battered torn ranks
the nva warriors killing any standing
enemy
they counted at least 50 nva dead
again eerie silence engulfed the team
and st
alabama regrouped just as suddenly a new
wave of nva soldiers rushed the
beleaguered team
st alabama had been pushed near
the cliff it was a thousand feet to the
ground if they went over the edge
now online st alabama charged through
the weakest nva flank
killing more enemy soldiers so you guys
are
there's thousand foot cliffs there's a
thousand foot cliffs that you guys are
up against
yeah jump off the cliff or go charge you
or not but it's
happened yeah and then so you guys
this is this is an important lesson for
people is
every time you guys are put into a tough
situation you go on the attack you
attack through the flank you attack
through the ambush
and right here st alabama charge through
the weakest nva
flank and that was
they did that several times and that's
what the nva they're not used to recon
teams
charging yeah and that's what saved
their lives at that point
yeah that's even though the vietnam guys
that taught us when i was a young seal
they would say if you get caught in an
ambush you have to attack them you if
you stay there you're just going to die
so you have to attack
exactly exactly quickly if we not attack
them
they're gonna run over us so we're gonna
attack them
and that they're scanning we can run
over to them
exactly about i'm continuing on here
something hit black
on the side of the head knocking him to
his knees he was scrambling to get up
when the grenade went off
the last thing he remembered was being
slammed into a tree face first and the
car 15 handled digging into his chest
so somebody hit him in that head with a
grenade yeah we don't know
where is that where they're from but
lucky for him
from the china there's a chinese
handkerchief they're poorly made
yes they met by their mission
by themselves in the jungle was that
right oh okay it was like a homemade
grenade
wow he thought he was drowning but he
but then he felt
feet kicking him and hands slapping him
all over it was the team
they were beating black back into
consciousness and pouring water on his
face
he tried to get up but his legs didn't
work from the knees down there were no
fatigue pants just
surface bleeding one of the guys started
smearing
gelatinized rice on the one two's legs
arms and chest
black's web gear and what was left of
his fatigue jacket were lying shredded
bloody on the ground
the car 15 was bent where the barrel
meets the receiver and the bolt couldn't
be
pulled back one of the team buried it by
zero 900 word of st alabama's precarious
position had spread through fob one
through fob one like wildfowler wildfire
requests were made for an extra assets
it was now an official
prairie fire emergency all aircraft were
pulled from their missions and sorties
to support
st alabama any gunships attached to sag
were summoned to their aid
the first gunships to arrive were marine
hueys known as scarface
with them was a ch-46 with a ladder
attached for jungle extraction
when the twin rotor helicopter entered
the ao it was hammered by heavy enemy
ground fire
as were the marine gun ships green
tracers were seen going toward the ch-46
the ground fire became too intense and
the marine chopper had to withdraw
and make an emergency landing at camp
eagle in the 101st airborne compound
despite this despite the hit scarface
gunships made several passes expanding
all
ordinance before returning to base to
reload
king b officers regrouped and prepared
to fly back to laos to extract what was
left of st alabama
the s3 asked for volunteers for a bright
light mission
and every recon men in fob1 volunteered
st idaho was scheduled to insert into
the prairie fire ao
the next day 6 october because the team
was ready to go
there was some initial discussion about
idaho being the bright light team
as the day dragged on however and the
perilous nature of st
alabama's situation worsened the bright
light option faded because the original
lz
was now too deadly for any helicopter to
attempt an extraction
so you were you were you and s were you
though one one yeah we were either one
zero and
one at that point yeah don walker was
the ones here so you guys are going like
we'll go we'll go now
yeah we're getting ready for our mission
on october 6th and then we're all ready
i said you guys are ready so we're going
to do the bright light and then they
change their mind later because of all
the intense fire another
helicopter got shot down in the process
unbelievable day so watkins watkins was
the covey
right they took they rotated watkins
then when the cubby got low on fuel and
spider parks was there
and he got low on fuel pat went back
back so they were both the two uh cubby
guys were there because they were really
familiar with that
target by that time so here we go when
watkins
who's the covey returned at the fob
for the cessna to refuel he told the
others that it didn't look good
he wasn't sure if they'd be able to get
them out he explained the low sunken
area in the lz the spotty weather and
how smoke from the expended ordinance
hung over the lz making it more
difficult to spot the team
and to deliver air strikes accurately a
resupply of ammo grenades claymore mines
m79 rounds water bandages and morphines
and morphine was placed on a king bee
and launched towards st alabama
in laos cowboy worked on black's legs he
told black that the last wave of nva had
continued
on to the lz cowboy and black heard more
u.s marine qe gunships arrive overhead
and witnessed the nva on the lz open
fire
hammering the lead aircraft again the
one one panicked cried and shouted
skyward
the vietnamese team members speaking
through cowboy told black that they were
going to kill the 1-1 if you didn't shut
up
black agreed i'll pull the trigger
myself
god forgive you the one one responded
tearfully
you and your god have no place here
black retorted cowboy grabbed the
startle black by the throat and lifted a
catholic crucifix from his neck
and shoved his lips to it it's the gods
who have allowed us to get this far
round eye
[Laughter]
so this is just a nightmare of a
situation
what are you guys doing on the ground
while all this uh close air support
is coming in i
can tell you the first thing in here
that you know when
when when the black down you know the
water
in the jungle we cannot you know
wave right right but we still pour whole
kind of water to him
to make him wake up i mean we don't know
our situation
we don't know the water how weird and
how the water in in his anger
but we still do it because we love him
very much
and the thing you know we
i don't know how to tell you
i don't know how to tell you but
we gotta protect by god i don't know
time
divine intervention yes
maybe all that praying helped
you know we only pray only or liberally
at the end of the the way we go
on at the end of the the thing in my
mind
we shoot them they should
and then if the god not protect me
not protect our team member
could not stay here that
hundred percent for true that's what i
told you i can tell you it
i came amazing the time
he lied out i'm crying i said hey black
black black
the only one you know we can believe
one one i cannot tell anything
how he can do anything to him
even you know we respect him a lot
but at the time what should we do
in my mind god
protect us please
become we have a new chain we haven't
know where to go
we can do anything they got a thousand
thousand we have
only figure only seven guys
because we did 200 and three wounded
i got a wounded myself m79 wounded
black black gwyneth
m 79 right now the uh
the ammo the bullet
and almost we use a knife
but lucky for us i mean we can
pick up the ak-47
and the weather from the communists and
we still protect
we can protect us out on the ground
so i can tell you because when
that's all my heart and only my heart
even you know james strikes still back
still back there two three vietnamese
bodies still back there
we can't do anything when greeting up
that
make me feel you know that depressed
i can honor to tell you about
so i don't know
why maya and me
still alive in here i don't know that
magic
by the way this isn't even over yet
that's not even close
yeah going back to the book the sound of
the approaching king bees ended the
religious debate as the realities of a
surviving a
shell hell became center focus the
able-bodied picked up the wounded and
moved toward the lz
spider the kovi rider at the time told
black that the first kingby was
enroute to the lz but they planned to
work the area surrounding st alabama
with tactical air support first in this
case
an f4 phantom jet pilot told black to
key your handset for 10 seconds and put
your head in the dirt
black acknowledges his radio
transmission and told his teammates to
put their heads down
as he looked into the sun he observed
the slowest moving full flapped phantom
he had ever seen
the glide path ratio was critical
seconds later
he saw the tree line across the lz
explode into sheets of
white yellow and orange flames setting
the jungle on fire with napalm
the ship banked sharply appearing to
stand its wing tips on the ground the
pilot cranked the burners
dropped down into the valley below and
then began a vertical climb
nva small arms opened up on all sides of
the valley
the the f4 took numerous hits on its
armor-plated underbelly
among those shooting at the fast mover
were several nva troops about 20 feet
from st alabama's perimeter
as the napalm torched the jungle dozens
of nva soldiers
scurried into the open field to escape
the instant inferno that engulfed their
comrades
as a second gent rolled in for a gun run
the nva initiated what they called
getting close to the belt in this case
the nva
soldiers moved toward or outright
charged st alabama
to get as close to the team members as
possible to avoid being hammered or
burnt by the air force marines or army
air
ordinance firing on single shot st
alabama picked
off each of them as they came out of the
burning jungle
the phantoms returned before returned
with two cannon
and minigun runs along the team's
perimeter before the dust settled the
vietnamese team later foe
team leader though and cowboy crawled
out and recovered
several ak-47s and precious ammunition
from the dead enemy soldiers
as their car 15 ammo was dwindling to a
few precious rounds
so you're crawling out and actually
grabbing the enemy weapons and
grabbing enemy ammunition from the dead
soldiers
that soldier they land out there i pick
it up
deliver to another member because
in order to survive we gotta do it
we're gonna do it we can't eat the body
enemy put up make the chain back
to protect our people too
using enemy bodies as sandbags to
protect yourselves yes
you go it goes on here two of the nine
cylinder king bees came
chugging up the valley toward st alabama
black popped a green smoke
marker the nva popped an identical smoke
marker confusing the pilots with
devastating results the first can be
kingby followed the nva smoke marker
and took a direct hit from a rocket
which toppled it on its side
smashing each rotor blade into the
ground the approaching st alabama team
members
narrowly missed getting hit with
shrapnel from the crash black cowboy
and another team member charged the
rocket position killing the three
nva before a hail of nva fire drove them
back into the team perimeter
the second h-34 hit an outcropping of
rock on the western side of the knoll
after taking heavy enemy gunfire it
exploded and fell
thousand feet to the valley floor below
taking with it
st alabama's resupply
covey barked nice going blackjack
[ __ ] you covey he replied cowboy told
the one one to pray for everyone except
black because he was going on the
devil's side
black broke into laughter as he assessed
st alabama's predicament
ammo was desperately low the blood
trails looked like slug slime
the f4 phantoms had expended their
ordinance and covey was belligerent
his nerves were shot training and a
man's basic survival instinct had
completely taken over
then the nva bugles sounded
so at this point
this scene you guys are running out of
ammo ammunition you got three wounded
you got two dead
no more than two dead you're you're
you're
taking enemy weapons off the ground
you're building a bunker
with enemy bodies the helicopters
finally show up to
get you out of there and they both get
shot out of the sky
yes
what do you think your chances are for
survival at this point
this only can i can say that god protect
us
no one can no one can
even not only to to chop
it down we got a lot of support
up the air like a phantom like a
skyrider
look at the ch 53 charlie green giant
we can see the bird you know it's over
the air
oh the other time not only to a lot
so you can actually see your air support
they're flying around
they're dropping bombs they're dropping
napalm but it doesn't really help i mean
the fact that you guys are
on the ground even though you can see
them yes
i can see it and then any enemy very
and then we on the ground we can point
sky rider bomb is in there
and then they're very scary that's why
we survive
another reason that in this day god came
in the form of
close air support yes absolutely a1
skyraiders were next
on you can see that keep your [ __ ]
head down
yeah bomb next to me yeah bomb negative
yeah
because they ups the air they know
what's going
where we are you know in the hat
we got a panel yep we turn over
yep so the airplane can see where we
were
right we used to do the same thing yes
was that right yep
that's another thing the vietnam guys
taught us inside of our floppy hat we
would sew an air panel in there so we
could flip it over and let let the
helicopters or
gunships know where i should have worn a
floppy hat what were you wearing
my little bandana oh you're too cool for
the floppy hat huh
i forgot about that yeah we we we have a
hat
yes inside the head we got a sure the
the panel
the communists they don't they don't
know anything about
and then exactly bombed to the
to the enemy and that's lynn black was
on the radio
running all the auto gun runs and all
their weapons
like it right there they say hey
nine o'clock but
200 feet bomb it there right away
and i want to hit you i say 12 o'clock
five feet and next to me you see it
peace yeah we we can control the
airplane because the pack
and pet walking and then spider now for
the covey yes
and they're able to give them the
control together
we control everything but
the people outside saying how do we
survive
it's easy to survive
because we there we saw the bomb
because like you said you read earlier
in the story they declared a prairie
fire emergency so when the first ones
out of marines scarface
when they expended then the the f1s came
in then the a1 skybraiders
and then later we had army yeah you know
judging executioner
they came out yeah we understand exactly
coming is you know very upright
airplane even they get a big gun
or they got a tank they're very scanning
yeah they're the 275 rockets many guns
we underground
they want to kill us it's very difficult
and they want to kill us because they
are afraid about you know their
their area gets destroyed by the bomb
we there we're not authorized to shoot
the people
but we can call airplane even at night
or a day
we gotta you know like communication
with the uh
with the air right basically at night we
got a moon beam
moon beam at night and then greenberg
the airborne night
from the airborne command show okay for
all southeast asia
so they would fly over and they would do
common checks at night which is
during the day would be hillsboro sort
of um
and they stayed close and support they
were way above
all the activity with the covey and the
fast movers so that that's one other
level of communication so if anything
dropped off
like the coveys were in between they
could still talk to hillsborough
and then still direct the gun ships for
that talk directly to the gun ships or
helicopter crew
now and lynn did all that yeah great job
when he was yeah with shock we got it
you know the [ __ ]
we understand exactly so we're not
afraid
we're only small group they cannot find
us
but they got big group hey
you there you got a big time thank you
hello
how are you doing goodbye yes well i'll
tell you speaking of communications i
can't imagine
a more horrific sound to hear than the
sound
of the bugles from the communists
getting ready to attack that's got to be
a nightmare
well we we come there
there their house they're afraid to
detroit their house
so we want to they want to kill us
it's not not easy not going to be easy
yet not easy
because we learn a lot we're training a
lot
we know when when we came down there we
got a briefing right
how many enemy underground
where we can hide them where we can
put the top i mean
m14 my top purpose
yeah top up where we can put it play mo
mai
we can put it there c4
and we know situation on the ground
we know every everywhere especially we
get experience in the jungle
and you american
you know situation you know how
knowledge
with the american i'm
vietnamese or whatever i'm know i'm
better than
the people from the north so we
i understand exactly when they're moving
i look in the jungle i look in the
mountain
and i can see it how
where are they and that way you could
help lynn black
direct the airstrikes or you saw the
most enemy activity
yeah right here by the way
day by day we get experience i'm not too
good
but with my experience i can look it up
this year the mountain here mountain
here
i can say hey i'm right here
say hey black we down here i
read the location for him
and then that way it is
but then after the bugle blew then
things got
ugly again yeah here by then you had
your your walls built
yeah let me pick it up so the nva bugle
sounded
waves of nva troops carrying sks's with
fixed bayonets
advanced on st alabama when they were 15
feet away st alabama opened fire the
semi-automatic sks were no match for the
fully automatic firepower of the spike
team
after the first burst of full automatic
fire the team went to single shot
it was another turkey shoot without a
word a look
or a plan acting solely on instinct all
of them
except the one one scurried forward and
dragged back
dead nva placing the bodies in a circle
around them and stacking them high the
deadly skirmishing continued for several
hours before covey told black that more
gunships and five
jolly green giants with heavily armored
sikorsky
hh3es were end enroute
blackjack covey what you're up against
is the regiment you are sent to find
over and blackjack replies is that all
only three thousand of the bastards well
i think we made a dent in them
who's winning they are covey responded
as black finished his como he saw a site
he would never forget the nva formed a
front line of nva troops
who were firing their ak-47s behind them
were several nva soldiers swinging
thongs made of leather and cloth
which held three to five hand grenades
each with a jerk of their collective
wrists the nva
hurlers launched more than two dozen
communist manufactured grenades at st
alabama the sky was full of grenades
fortunately they weren't us grenades
they hit the ground and threw dirt smoke
and dust all over the place
st alabama looked up just as the aks
started again
and behind them the thongs whirling
overhead like helicopter blades
when the aks stopped the grenades were
released
st alabama fired more grenades were
released
alabama threw some back st alabama
was caught in a deadly version of the
kid game pop goes the weasel
the ak-47s continued to roar alabama
ducked
the grenades were launched alabama
rocked catch
duck throw duck catch throw
the nva advanced grenade shrapnel
several severed the antenna of the prc
25 radio
he quickly black quickly rigged an
impromptu antenna from wire the
relentless nva continued to advance
inch by bloody inch
cowboy took two vietnamese team members
over the cadaver walled perimeter
seeking to get another line of fire to
direct at the
advancing nva the advance continued
despite firing from black and the
remaining vietnamese team members
the nva were now merely feet away from
the perimeter
sheesh do you believe it
i can't believe you're sitting here
talking to me
really even now yeah jeez
throwing bunches of grenades
that's just a horror show that's crazy
that's the first time we ever saw that
right yes
yeah a new tactic
we live in here
stay here here the village
and down here the first thing we we're
at the top
so there's a re so there's a little
ridge line yes and they're on one side
of the ridge line
yeah you're on the other side of the
ridge line
and then they shoot up we're going down
here we move
to you know we got a high in here the
cover
earth and ganette troll here oh so
they're throwing grenades over the red
joint at you
and then
as you i say that combination not
training well so if
you know that you're gonna have to put
it out
come in here one two three four they
throw it
we're gonna die everybody but they just
pulled the pin and they just pulled the
pin
they didn't cook them at all yes and we
have a time
you have a timer to pick it up and throw
it back
because because they are not well
training
but with us hanging at it
put it out tum it one
two three control it when they pick it
up
it's gonna blow it out that's why
we can suggest it
communist it's not well training
or whatever they're not training at all
they just know put it out and throw it
that's why we're lucky for you yeah we
still survival
the people they understand they say hey
the guy is liar no
it's not a liar but they're trending it
not
not not not well not good
so that's why we we're here meyer
that's why we're here
going back to the book at the last
moment with the nva a few
body lengths away from the perimeter two
huey gunships
from the american division the 176th
aviation company the minutemen
muskets of the 36 charlie arrived the
uh-1b
pilots were code named the judge and the
executioner
they roared into battle first with a
mini gun blast followed seconds later
with several 2.75 millimeter rockets
placed in the nva ranks alabama was
saved if only for a little while
the nva backed off for a few moments
briefly licking their collective wounds
although they were far from whipped new
assault lines of the nva troops formed
before the nva opened fire on st alabama
however
the executioner confronted the nva head
on
with both door gunners blazing away with
their handheld m60 machine guns
he hovered inches off the ground between
the team in the front of the nva
and skipped several 2.75 millimeter
rockets
off the ground into the nva before the
bleeding
startled nva could respond the pilot
lifted the old uh-1b
model gunship over the tree line and
ducked down into the canyon regaining
enough airspeed to return for another
pass
at the st alabama perimeter
before st alabama could celebrate the
nva charged again
three more dead nva were added to the
cadaver wall
silence dominated the battlefield no
bird chirps no speaking no noise of any
type
even the aircraft over the scene had
flown far enough away
that their absence amplified the empty
air the one one who hadn't fired a
single shot continued to pray
black patched up a bleeding cowboy he
gave him some morphine
before bandaging a wound on the right
side on his right side from an ak-47
round
where's john wayne when you need him
cowboy asked
the others laughed chew hoy dumas
give up [ __ ] an enemy soldier
yelled
another nva told black to chew hoy in
english
black flipped him the bird as a sniper
sniper shot alabama's tail gunner
quang is that right quan clong in the
crotch
hitting an artery as though a pried
direct pleasure pressure to kwon's
wound an a1e skyraider lumbered into the
ao
flown by pilot codenamed snoopy he
roared in from black's left brushing the
treetops full flaps working his throttle
the aircraft was so close to the team
that black could hear the distinctive
metallic click click of the napalm
canisters
being released from the old korean war
era plane the skyraider appeared to be
falling but it actually
slipped down into the valley to escape
nva gunfire
as the american uh-1b gunships and fast
movers had maneuvered earlier in the day
his wing man appeared as he flew and he
as he flew over the team
they could hear the nuts and bolts of
god knows what creaking and groaning as
he saw the salvo
the rockets the nva were pissed again
the hot shell casings from the airborne
warships rained down on st alabama
where's john wayne when you need him
the great line that's right cowboy yeah
oh and where where did you go you got
shot with ak
yes do you want to
you want to see scar
i'll take your word for it sir he's got
so many scores
and that is garb
um yeah it's crazy to think you're so
close to these guys that you're talking
to them
yelling out chu hoy choo hoi du ma
oh yeah god they all the way cold
they what the enemy all the way
chi
uh then three small mortars opened fire
black knew there was no way in hell any
of the teams could catch the mortars and
throw them back
he and the vietnamese team leader though
rolled over the cadaver wall toward the
mortars cautiously picking their way
through the charred nva bodies and
carnage from the previous airborne
assaults
they moved into the jungle within 20
feet of them first mortar tube though
drew a plan in the ground he would hit
tube one black would hit tube three and
they'd compine on
tube two after the mortarman launched
three salvos though opened on his target
while black attacked his target tube and
several nva
several nearby nva soldiers the
survivors chased black
in the confusion the nva opened fire on
each other as black headed toward tube
one
with nva soldiers still chasing him
where tho was pinned down
black threw a hand grenade and killed at
least three nva with a blast of gunfire
to free throw
they turned on the nva chasing black and
dealt with them
then he and tho wiped out the nva at the
second tube before they quickly returned
to the team
all while picking up ammo and loaded
ak-47 magazines from dead or wounded nva
soldiers
by now watkins had returned to flying
covey rider above st
alabama spider had called the u.s air
force 37th air rescue and recovery group
in da nang to attempt to rescue
s the rest of sqst alabama during the
vietnam
war when pilots were shot down in the
north in north vietnam or laos and all
else failed
the jolly greed giants were called the
sikorsky
hh-3e weighed 22 000 pounds loaded and
had two general electric t-58 ge5 turbo
shaft
1500 horsepower engines extra armament
and firepower and they were manned by
remarkable air force pilots and crews
the first heavily armored jolly green
giant code named jg28 started its
descent to the lz from 4 000
feet as it approached the jg crew was
looking for an orange panel on the south
east side of the lz however as the
aircraft was about to touch down crew
members noticed a second panel
the nva had an identical panel the
momentary pause was nearly fatal for
jg28
as the nva opened fire on it from
several sides the heavy gun fire severed
the main
fuel line causing a massive fuel leak
inside the helicopter
jg28 had to withdraw from the lz in a
matter of seconds there were two or
three inches of aviation fuel
on the aircraft's cabin floor the fumes
temporarily blinded the crew members
the pilot was able to stabilize and
return to da nang
as jg10 hovered a safe distance away
from the lz
watkins directed a few more airstrikes
around st alabama
with the hope that the communist
soldiers would put their heads down long
enough for the team to get out
after a few ear air strikes jg 10
piloted by air force major vernon sam
grineer
was called to attempt the extraction for
grineer this was his first assignment in
the prairie fire ao as a jolly green
giant pilot
hey welcome to welcome to prairie fire
oh yeah
when the call from covey came grineer
knew that there were two
u.s green berets on the ground with
their vietnamese team members and that
the majority of the team was wounded he
didn't hesitate
grineer piloted the jolly green giant
toward the lz unlike jg28 grineer
knew which side of the lz st alabama was
on
as he approached the lz nva gunfire
again reached a deafening roar
despite st alabama directing firepower
at the communist
soldiers as grineer began to hover over
the lz
jg10 was hammered by enemy gunfire
his crew chief reported that one nva
round had tore a six inch hole through
the floor
the round apparently slammed into one of
the engines both engine warning lights
went on
both engines were on fire grineer did a
180 degree turn and moved to damaged
aircraft away from the deadly enemy fire
and away from the team
struggling to keep it airborne calling
upon all the training he had received to
continue flying
both crew members continued firing their
machine guns as grineer battled to keep
the ship in the air
time ran out for jg10 after traveling
several hundred yards grineer warned his
crew to brace
themselves for a crash landing both crew
members continued
firing their weapons until the burning
hh-3e
slammed into the jungle
st alabama was stunned covey and all the
men flying over the target
area viewed the horror in grim silence
what's that four helicopters have gone
down now five
including the first the first one on
insert four
four
the men back at fob1 monitored the radio
transmissions
on their prc-25s as covey talked to
black
spike team alabama's radio signal was
too weak to hear any response the word
spread through camp that the latest
horrific turn of events
surrounding st alabama the usual hustle
bustle
of a saturday at fob1 was replaced by
quiet hushed tones as the entire
compound feared the worst
but continued to pray for the men of st
alabama
word of a proposed arclight mission
reinforced the gravity of sd alabama's
situation
an arc light was a strike by a b-52
bomber
from more than 25 000 feet
back in laos the stunned members of st
alabama returned to their cadaver
perimeter once again
nearly out of ammo one one was facing
down
muttering the lord is my shepherd one of
the vietnamese went about collecting
ak-47s and ammo
from the dead nva as spyder and watkins
directed more airstrikes around the team
within 10 to 15 minutes after grineer's
burning hh3
crashed into the jungle covey learned
that there were two survivors from the
jolly green giant and asked st alabama
if they could locate the remaining crew
members
grineer had broken his back but somehow
pulled himself from the burning
helicopter the other jolly green giant
survivor
sergeant ernest dean casbier had been
thrown clear of the crash
neither knew the location of the other
watkins told black where the air force
survivors
were and that they'd run a daisy chain
between his position and the men
hopefully to clear the area
enough for the team to get to both of
the survivors
the nva threw one more curve at st
alabama when black tried to talk to
covey he found the primary secondary and
alternate
fm frequencies jammed by the nva
frustrated black smashed the prc 25 and
pulled out his urc
10 high frequency survival radio he was
told
an arc light strike was being planned
for this area
as soon as possible by now
all air assets navy marine and air force
which had been scheduled to fly sorties
into north vietnam
were diverted to the prairie fire
emergency surrounding st alabama
covey directed numerous airstrikes
including more gun and rocket runs from
helicopter gunships
scarface and huey's from the marine
light helicopter squadron 367 returned
to make several runs
after refueling and reloading and fubai
the minute minutemen muskets returned to
wreak havoc
on the persistent nva troops they
pounded the jungle area between sd
alabama and air force survivors
around 1800 a jolly green
pilot air force major don olson called
over the radio
blackjack jg32 over i'm parked down in
the drought
draw in the trees from you you have 20
minutes of fuel before i leave
the first person we must see is an
american
hurry we're taking heavy ground fire
sheesh so now it's six o'clock at night
you've been there all day on the ground
four helicopters down
you got two survivors that you're gonna
try and link up with
and then jolly green just came down to
the jungle and hovered in the jungle
just to just waiting
lower his profile and to wait yeah it's
a counterintuitive thing that when
you're in an aircraft and you're in a
helicopter or a plane
when you're up higher it makes you an
easier target it's better to get
low where the enemy can't see you so i
know it might not make sense people
might think oh it'd be better to
go up but it's actually in a lot of
cases better to go down
and that's what this guy's doing
anything that couldn't be carried was
thrown over the side of the cliff
as quickly as the wounded could move
they headed toward the jolly green giant
could you guys hear the helicopter did
you know where it was
yes so you could hear it and you're like
okay we gotta go for it
yes the chopper had literally cut away
the treetops and branches to
nestle into the thick dark green foliage
thus reducing its profile to enemy
gunners olsen had to keep the aircraft
stable as there were large trees on all
sides of the aircraft the trees were
large enough
that they could severely damage the five
rotor blades and cause the trapper
tropper to crash if
any of them got hit covey directed more
airstrikes in a daisy chain fashion
in the portion of jungle between st
alabama and the hovering jolly green
giant
watkins hoped this would drive out or
kill nva in the zone
even that task became more difficult as
smoke from all the ordinance continued
to hang over the trees
decreasing the visibility for pilots and
helicopter gunners
as they move toward the hovering
helicopter sd alabama
entered a cool ravine before climbing a
final hill to the chopper
there they encountered a village with
hooches built on 10-foot stilts
complete with large pots cooking rice
and vegetables
instead of nva troops black found an
american
taking food from one of the pots he was
the flight engineer
sergeant ernest dean caspier one of the
two air force survivors from the crashed
helicopter
soon they found grineer who assisted in
directing
the hovering jolly green to this area in
the jungle despite his broken back
you want to talk about miracles yeah
randomly running into these guys
in the village in the village jeez
but we know we need two guys
to survive yeah you knew that you were
looking for them
well lg is here
the jolly green tennis dropped down here
it
crashed we run from here all the way
down here
you know the communist house around here
we got a difficult time to
join with them so that's why we
take you know very crazy
decision we go or we
go fast or we go slowly or we go
you know the by another way to
get in to join with them
this from from from the hill here
to the castle it's a
very difficult time for us
but we got to do it you know
like at 18 o'clock right it's
a little bit dark so it's starting to
get dark
and black and angle keys want to say hey
we stay here for
overnight but
i thought in my mind if i stay overnight
i gotta die because my bleeding in the
back
every thing in my body i say hey let me
let me join first
and i run through but we had a tactical
to escape from the uh
from here to the grass side i said
go fight and
coin and you got a two gun
this fight ding
and then i run so you just kind of went
for it yes
and then they stayed and were you
were you trying to get to where the
helicopter was yes and you were just
going to go by yourself
yes because otherwise you were going to
bleed out yes
at what point did the rest of the team
decide to go with you
they stay there i'm the point
to open the negative broadway
to let if i'm die
if the team get it to be deceptive
if i run to and then when i get there
i gotta shoot my ding ding and a team
run
okay so you're gonna they were covering
for you yes
and then when you got there you covered
for them yes
and then when i run there i say hey i
saw the job there
and i stayed there i say go
when we don't have a radio but when i
started
the people understand i'm safety
and then quang they gotta run through my
my way
we rejoin in there with the helicopter
side
we understand if i'm staying overnight
i'm gonna die because they're bleeding
sure
and then anyway i gotta i die
let's try let's try to looking for the
way
for survival right
so you you didn't you were either going
to die trying to run there
or you're going to die staying there
overnight yes so you might as well
either way you don't eat the thing i
gotta die
if i'm stay there and you already had
died what three times four times at this
point your career
but you know how do we hear
we still you know understand we
training well we're training good
and then we work together really good if
i'm running
if quang and black or whatever
can protect me they give you cover yeah
cover fire i gotta die
in my way and the nva wasn't used to you
guys
running yes they didn't expect it no
again they just before they charge
through the ranks several times
and then this one here he's running and
then the others follow
another one ding ding ding ding you know
right there
and you're firing with ak-47s by now so
that way
um the nva maybe wouldn't be so alert if
they heard car 15 they would come
quickly for the car 15s but hearing aka
maybe they weren't sure that may have
helped those we still have
one or two car 15. really you know we
you know the way car 15 the the front
yes we put we take it
in the front of the m16 yes we put in
a car 15 different shower
for a different one okay different
shower
so when i started
like it there like like a michigan
right but the car 15 that the long one
in here yes
it's very small but when we shoot it
by the uh i don't know how to call it
but you know the front of it is the
it's the flash on the end yes yes so the
difference
this is about two inches yeah right here
they had the early m16
oh okay the three prong ones yes yes
very early m16 with that three prong and
they
they changed the flash which i've never
heard before different shapes are a
different sound
very different sound they're very
difficult oh yeah yeah
you know the kind of one more thing that
saved you yeah one more team
you're running you're bleeding and
you're firing car 15s but different
sound
along with the aks and they knew that
and then
they followed me and then at the time
they followed me
i got ping ping your
just single shots yeah if you put full
automatic you don't have a
good enough you know the ammo so the
ping we count maybe we can
play game with them one two three ping
one two three ping ping sometime
and if they scan it if you
fools you know the automatic they say
hey
that's got it no experience in the world
he's an amateur
yes and easy to run out the emma
yeah ping and not bing bing bing
different different way different style
so they know
the uh you know the people with the
anime
they understand exactly those guys
how how they're learning so
according from the from the training
we're doing well we're doing good very
good
so any situation anywhere and any time
training counts yes so just
you know just let the people understand
that in the army now
you better learn you better train don't
be
don't say hey i'm hero i'm hero i'm the
big guy no
no we need to training always trade
trending all the way
learn from each other if james dry
he listened to me he said hey how do we
get out
and that's easy right call the chopper
i need attraction and then we shape the
everybody
but anyways get back to here where you
are now yes sir yeah
well where we are right now is back to
the book the nva focused heavily on the
chopper
easing the pressure on st alabama as
they neared the jolly green
black thought it felt like they were
moving closer to the gates of hell
itself the nva were pouring small arms
firing rpgs at the hovering ship all the
door gunners and pilots intermittently
fired the mini-gun m-79s and m-60s and
the helicopter gun ships and skyraker
skyraiders made gun runs around it time
was against them the weather was
beginning to close in
the smoke from previous airstrikes hung
over the area for longer and longer
periods of time before clearing enough
for the next attack from the air on the
ground the men of st alabama
heard an nva running through the bushes
around them
fortunately the nva failed to spot the
spike team or the air force crewman
desperate black had to move his team
onto a trail so it could move
to the hovering helicopter more quickly
as the team moved up the trail the tail
gunner was shaking
violently and had turned a pasty white
team members set quang down and
proceeded to the aircraft at the crest
of the hill they saw the helicopter
taking hits and dealing out its own the
m-60 was red-hot
black saw someone firing an m16 out of
one of the windows
as black moved to the chopper the
intensity of gunfire seemed to multiply
the air was so full of lead he could
see it fuel and bits of metal skin fell
from the aircraft as they reached its
underside
the jungle penetrator smashed to the
ground next to him and raised three feet
before he could put
three team members on the first load
grineer the
the air force flight engineer and the
wounded
st alabama team member were second were
on the second hoist lift
the wounded vietnamese became entangled
in jungle vines and while
was while he was being hoisted upward
the air force
hoist operator had to stop the hoist
lower it and give him enough time to
untangle himself
when the hoist moved up toward the
aircraft the vietnamese was not sitting
in the seat but hanging on
with assistance from air force sergeant
kazbeer
despite the nva gunfire black ran back
to the bamboo thicket where he had left
the remainder of the team
cuong the dying tail gunner pointed his
45 caliber pistol at the advancing nva
and said toy quiet i die
he motioned black to return to the
helicopter
before shooting himself
black was running back to the ship when
two nva stepped onto the trail
and pointed their ak-47s at him chu hoy
one of the soldiers shouted
black stretched out his arms and
continued walking towards them
when he was only a few feet away he said
chew hoi
the young nva soldiers appeared
surprised before they could react
black grabbed the ak-47s by their
searing barrels
and stripped them from their soldiers he
backhanded the soldier on his right
and smashed the other soldier in the
face with one of the weapons he left the
stunned soldiers lying there as he
sprinted to the chopper where he found
the praying one-one
the rest of the team was on board firing
any weapon they could get their hands on
as the jungle penetrator lift black and
the 1-1 upward
they were showered with hot spent
casings from the m60 and other weapons
being fired from inside the aircraft the
entire team
fired out the windows and from the back
door
as the overloaded helicopter began to
lift out of the jungle
major olson told covey he was at maximum
power
as the jolly green giant slowly rose
black felt the ship making upward surges
from b-40 rockets slamming into the
armor-plated underside of the aircraft
it felt like it was a giant
it felt like a giant slugging the ship
in the stomach boosting it upward
with each rocket blast from his view
abrupt the fray
watkins couldn't believe the bird kept
flying somehow
the pilot got the jolly green giant out
of there
once clear of the jungle hole the ship
began its ascent out of the valley
and the shadow of death the door gunner
removed
his helmet and placed it on black's head
the pilot told him we're on our way home
not quite from above watkins saw the
crippled ship
catch fire and try to make and try to
make it out of the killing zone
it crossed two ridgelines before
descending into a clearing where it
crash landed
olson had gotten them out of the killing
zone but jg32 had flown its last rescue
mission
everyone except black in the 1-1 were
transferred to another jolly green giant
piloted by a coast guard exchange pilot
lieutenant commander lonnie mixon
mixon took over 30 hits picking up st
alabama and
others after everyone
after everyone knew that black the
remaining personnel from st alabama and
the air force survivors from jg10 were
cleared from the original target area
they hammered it with everything they
had including more napalm bombs and gun
runs
captain hartness the pilot of watkins
fak plane was so mad at that he flew
the o2 down into small arms range and
fired his 2.7 millimeter rockets into
the area
where the nva had knocked down jg10 he
and watkins took a hit to the front
and the engine died hartness somehow got
the skymaster o2
up out of the area and back to fubai
there was no engine pressure when he
landed
a cobra gunship landed and opened the
armament compartment doors which had
seat belts attached to them
black and the 1-1 buckled up and were
soon airborne alongside the
jolly green giant returning to da nang
they were flying so fast that black had
to turn his blood-stained face away
in order to breathe within minutes he
was so cold he was shivering
uncontrollably
the cobra landed at a marine medevac
site where the americans were wrapped in
poncho liners
and helicopter to da nang at the danang
infirmary
everyone was getting patched up when
foe saw black he raised his right hand
and a fist above his head
chu hoy du ma he yelled
surrender [ __ ]
man that's a crazy mission
what do you think just another day in
sog absolutely
yeah maybe just a little bit today
and that was i mean that's one mission
but that was your life
that was your life that's what you did
every day
or or multiple times a month over and
over and over and over again
[Music]
over again i mean the the casualty rate
for sog
was was uh over 100 correct
so if you were going to sag you are
going to get wounded probably more than
once
you may be killed obviously i can't
imagine that the survival rate
for the vietnamese that aren't going
back
to america you're just staying in that
job
for years i mean their kid their
survival rate must have been
minuscule for you to be standing here is
crazy
absolutely it's a miracle actually
in our situation that we have no choice
we have no choice we have to go forward
okay the vietnam vietnamese
situation that vietnam war country
if i'm not joined to the army i get back
home
i cannot survive i must go with the
another
unit like infantry or
local local army
why not we stay with the shop
we got a lot of offering
we got a lot of money better pay yeah we
got it
you know the uh a lot of power when we
on
go back to town mm-hmm we got we
we wetted uh
envy this mva uniform
nobody can touch it because we have it
all right you know
the the car employee of the os
government so nobody can toast
whatever they cut they want to toast it
we got a mp military police there
to protect us and we got a gun in the
front we got a gun
pistol in the back come on
whatever 10 guy or 20 guy
have you watched it in a rambo movie or
something
we did like 100 like him
we gotta claim our mind here we gotta go
somewhere
we pull over here nobody now
anything else walk around with a
claymore mine on your chest right here
you wanna play go ahead come on please
even you know the police station
whatever they want to do with us we join
together with one team
three american and now
vietnamese we went together
nobody can stop us like the time that
quang was in jail you had to go get him
out of jail
yeah he had to break him out of jail
yeah kwang got in jail did they was it
was there resistance from the jail or
did they just let you guys take him
when they realized who you guys were no
we we went there for free
nobody can't stop we
we went there up in the here claymores
on your chest come on here please and
they also had a couple of guys with them
60s
15 years old kind of thing they're
looking top 15 they say hey
what the hell the girl need this right
yeah nobody knows
and we got an ak-47
if they shoot up grey mama i gotta blow
out
yeah so they let us do it quan got out
of jail
quan got out of jail he got the get out
of jail
claymore so he could go on a mission on
october 5th
and that's where he died yeah it's that
quan oh so that that's when you had to
break them out was before
this mission before this mission they
broke him out of jail geez
so basically you were in that job
because you guys were the baddest
[ __ ] in vietnam and you did
whatever you wanted to
yes sure
even you know the strong guy hey
claymore beats a strong guy all day long
all day
you know i can count the piece up the
the inside
555 piece ball bearings
i can't count
sometimes we play just play the game
right
put it down with c4 inside we took out
the uh we took out the c4
yeah sometimes they take it out and cook
their coffee and stuff oh yeah
and then we put it in here nobody knows
that the real world
is effective this is still psyops yeah
it's good good psychological operations
when did you uh because i know you ended
up getting wounded badly in your leg
when when did that happen it happened
august 30th 1971.
and then what what happened did you get
shot i guess so
and how did you get out of the how did
you escape the situation
he uh we don't know underground
but the water in there swam in there
and then we get out there
we're looking for with the people
experience like me we're looking for the
high the place and under the tree to
stay there
and they wanted they wanted me to be
build up live i mean they want to catch
the team
they the posting it
they want the first thing like it they
want a shot like it to here
you're out there to get a pow they want
to
yes they want me to do it they want me
to
they want they want to catch me
but we we we want to
not let them do it
and but after that they want what they
want to catch
the team they don't they don't want to
kill the team okay
they say surrender like a chillhoe
and then we entered the uh
by the cop15 he had a kachiohoi
but they very close to us they got a
bunker around there
and they shoot the guy with the radio
before they want to catch the team they
got to kill the radio man first
okay like the frenchman
he wear the radio they want to come make
the contact with the team they're going
to
kill the radio man first
and then my legget next to the radio
i pull i kick the radio
out but they shoot the reddit radio
including my leg
and maybe two three rounds into my leg
they they should buy
rpd the idea the child i know that i'm
sure he did
and then i pulled out my leg that time
we just get out there for 10 minutes
and team i just report to uh
the bingham bring him just report to the
uh kobe
say team septic team okay
and they can go home bingo was the team
leader yes
yeah they can go home and say and bing
him
yes and then
later on they got a hit right away and
my friend they carry me out the uh they
call back
they go back they go back to the chopper
just drop book come back
but you know i got it uh
prc uh 68
oh later on they know prc68 radio
mm-hmm emergency radio emergency radio
yeah
the prc68 that was still around when i
came in until really
yeah it was it was getting phased out
getting replaced by the prc 125 but
there was like
one or two of them that you could go
look at the radio show small one yeah
that's a small one
we got it now the yorkton uh oakton
right yes we got a 10 oh 10 we cannot
talk
but prc 68 we can change the frequency
to talk
oh okay that they got to develop the
the new thing and then when i turn it on
you know when i pull out the they gotta
try to be pull out me to the lg
and then i put it on and
the uh jumper coming back and shoot up
to the enemy
and i turned over my leg it really hurt
really pain
i told my
phd 68 away i'm dropped somewhere
and then they they thought i'm i'm dead
because after 10 minutes i cannot end
you know turn off turn up the brc
28 that mean i am the one dead
and they want to kill they want to blow
out the
plc68 they don't want brc68
to the hand the animation
and that's why i survived and
they shoot around us by the rocket
by the missile unkind of thing and the
mva
thought you know like at the
the job will know where they are they
move out
oh they they they were scared they
scanned it they moved it out
and i am free i'm not free but you know
i had it
i got a safety difficult situation
and the chopper laid down picked me up
and the first chopper went down
i smelled the gas because
the enemy shoot up the chopper
to the guest tank i say
get out of the way i i cannot shoot
because i shoot it
the uh the chopper you gotta burn it out
yes and i
wait my hand i said go go go go go go
and they talk to hold the team i say
don't shoot anything don't shoot
anything
and after that you know the the pilot
they knew you know the guests spread out
and they left i don't know what happened
what happened with the chopper
but the second one lay down pick me up
they take me to the 995th hospital
and then later on today
i got an inspection and then the doctor
cut up my leg
only 20 minutes on the ground
only 20 20 minutes when we land out
but i'm okay now
he's back so then what was it like
as the war was over and america
was leaving and the communists are
taking over
i mean you had to be kind of a marked
man
being this former you know special
operations guy that was working
alongside the americans they must have
wanted to find you
that's why i told you that we needed
training
up to i got wounded i was then to
work with the american embassy
okay so after you got wounded you went
to work at the american embassy yes
got it my station in danang
at 52 back down
u.s consulate general one in danang
until to 1975.
today we lost da nang at
uh the end of the march
1975
with my experience with the
shock we understand enemy situation
they fight from uh not to the south
but i work in the lana at the time you
know
the the
they want to take it along i move up to
the south
i hit a lot of enemy
i can't talk a lot of you know like the
security or
police what do you think
they moved they attacked from the north
to the south but i'm from the south move
up to the north
they thought i'm i'm there their friend
that's why i'm telling you we need to
train
so you did the opposite of what they
thought you would do
yes you went from the south to the north
to they're not then being
i'm the people from the north
they not pay attention about the people
from the south to the north
but if you move from this north to the
south
they got a checkpoint where you go
what is your name where do you work
everything to ask the question but i'm
from the north
from the south to the north the reason
that
my father-in-law of the way
of the fuguai fubai camp
and then we stayed there
until to they took over the saigon
and we almost crazy we don't know where
to go
we don't want to understand situation
but my family in the saigon
and a lot and even ben [ __ ]
after take over to the south vietnam
you know i use it enemy paperwork
that means nfp id card and
an enemy certificate i mean from from
the north
by the way my relief
my uncle
my something relief my nephew
up the north going to the south
to see me that mean when
when the first thing we 1954
we still have the people living in in
the north
and when they came down they're looking
for us because
between saigon and north vietnam it's
very difficult
very difficult and saigon it tricks
people and you know knowledge people
but in north vietnam they only
you know knowledge by the combination
you they limit limited with
education so when i when they came down
outside
when they came down to the south to see
our family
they don't have nothing but they still
say hey
we got a tv over the town we got all
kinds of things
but they have nothing but
at the time they asked for the money
they asked for the gold
they've asked for the drink that's why i
learned from them too so
i'm not stay only one place today i'm in
san jose tomorrow i'm lucky
i gotta go to tennessee and then i gotta
go
washington dc i gotta go you gotta keep
moving
keep moving keep the communists guessing
and then
i buy something everything in in the
communist
situation government everything it
not free like it
i want to uh i want to fish
i got to go down to see some
daenerys or somewhere i buy the fish
i took from there back to saigon to sell
the super
black market so i found out the way
by the way i'm looking for the way to
escape
from vietnam they give me sometime a
freak because they know
they knew i was
from the short man so soc
for free they invite us because they got
a gun but they don't know how to do
oh so they actually invited you the
communists invited you out
the the people in the vietnam oh south
vietnam
they invited you to start training them
no
to just do security for them to do what
to if we see anything happen in
overseas i got to shoot these guys yes
got it
let us protect them and then
until to 1986
october i successful to come
to malaysia
and how did you do that my small boat
small boat yes and you had tried
14 times before that the last time at
the 15th time
i got a paperwork right there and what
is that
you tried to escape so you tried to
escape 14 times you were successful on
your 15th time yes
what were the other methods that you
tried do you was it always by boat
by boat yes always by boat i'm going
back
i i i thought i got i gotta go i can go
buy a kitchen
or whatever the uh laos
with my leg cannot walk because i know
where the way to go
right i know where the way to go but you
know my leg
go west but you couldn't walk tonight
yes
and then what happened once you got to
malaysia
i'd be there for uh wait for the
uh uh i mean
uh i stay there
i see the uh american delegation
and they come to interview me
so they say and then they take me to the
uh
to come to the united states how do they
go
how do they confirm who you are i have
nothing but
you know they got a special interview
from the people from from the u.s
i mean gva them enjoy volunteer agents
agency when i came there i have nothing
but they ask me and i talk my history
they mm-hmm back here they call back
step to check up
right and after one month they say hey
you come who has so they did that pretty
fast
yes because they asked me
they got it you know group like they're
looking for the uh
for the pw or whatever m.i.a
they asked me the question do i know any
american
mission in action or i said yes i did
i talked uh poking
uh can't cry james strike
these are all people on our teams who
got killed and the two other americans
on alaska when it got wiped out when
when allen survived the two americans
were crying and king
i only i only remember with three
but they asked me do you know where the
location i said yes i did sure and they
tried to bring me back to the vietnam
to tell them but
they could because the time i stayed
there for
sigmund for waiting to
come back to vietnam but
i don't know why they sent me to the
philippines
for education training and what
kind of education training learning
learning you know like
for orientation for how the uh
american life and in there for sigmund
i came over here in san francisco
and then what was it like when you
landed in san francisco
1998 something 1988
yes what'd you do when you landed did
you have any family here
yes i got it uh my sister in
in san jose and had she escaped from
vietnam
yes already yes 1975
and how did she escape by uh
because some she had a
husband like the uh the vietnamese pilot
and they out of vietnam by the way
you know the uh her husband wow
so what did you do when you st when you
landed just have to start get a job and
i mean you couldn't strap a claymore to
your chest anymore and walk around town
taking what you wanted
my sister she be here like at the uh
75 and then she got
like a few air station fire gas station
and then i got when i came
i worked for her like a family shop
until i got you know like a uh
i got stroke 15 years ago
yeah 15 years 17 years ago i got stroked
and then at no more no more job no more
yeah that happened we all thought cowboy
finney
will never see cowboy gang we all heard
that i don't know
i don't think anything that can kill
cowboy at this point cowboy's gonna live
forever
so he has a struggle with a bad stroke
but yet he's back
my mouse you know over here
and i cannot move but now
i'm still gay but another problem that
eight inch or agent orange agent orange
i got a kidney problem i got
dialysis now at home
and you manage somehow to have kids
during all this
you have children yes i do and how many
children do you have
totally 10. do you believe it
i don't i don't i believe anything that
you tell me
three dead in the vietnam okay so you
lost three kids in vietnam
because when the newborn they don't have
you know any food they don't have any uh
like energy to to stay
live tree dead
and then when i escaped with the two of
my son
came over here with me my wife at the
time it's
still bike in the vietnam
and then i do my paperwork all my family
here right now
i got faison into her
in here with me in the united states
with me oh beautiful
one up the uh dixit
one of the north carolina and
three in here with me and two of my guru
went in here with me and another one
that the yeah i
i believe in louisiana yeah
and then i have a 16
no 11 wrong child 11 grandchildren
wow eleven little cowboys out there
little eleven little cowboys
so you are gonna live forever no doubt
no doubt
i try my best i try my best i cannot
tell
whatever you know like it when i got
shocked
my uh my uh my wife would say go now and
when i say hey
don't do it and then my son say call 911
and i cannot see it i cannot lie down
this is when you had your stroke yes you
said don't call 9-1-1 yeah no
you didn't want to call a prairie fire
emergency on that situation
no i call chopper
[Laughter]
you know because i have a training when
when i watch out i have a trending kung
fu
i got a training training yoga
and i keep you know i keep my body you
know free
i keep my mind going and later about
hour
i'm back to normal not normal that time
you know we cannot we can we can use it
you know
medication i say okay now call
9-1-1 take me to the doctor
with the time for emergency i learned
from my father
he crying when i lost my leg he said
he told me why i'm not using the hope
you know hope right hope i
hope medication hope is the medication
yes
not you know use it by the american way
medication they could take pill
or get shot they're no good so that's
why
i'm say don't call 9-1-1
wow and then i survival right now you
see it
i got a lot of trouble i know it affect
by the war
you know sometime it make me depressed i
got a lot of medication
and you know
they spread everything in the vietnam
agent orange we came down there
you know that we're very shocked with
the water
but we pull out the rock the water in
there
we take an hour drink
that's why i got a drama with my ace
right now because the agent orange
yes
well i'll tell you what i don't know uh
we've been going for two and a half
hours
no till we did what did we miss did i
miss anything
well the only thing we missed would be
if we if you want to talk about
the day he was with the frenchman
that historic day when the frenchman got
shot in the back four times yeah
if you remember that okay so one month
later you guys are on another mission
and i'm going i'm going back into across
the fence
here we go later in the afternoon
children signaled to the team to pull
their claymore mines and prepare to move
out
due to the combined weight of the
rucksack and web gear letourneau
as the frenchman moved to his knees and
slung his rucksack on his back
just as it landed on his back ak-47s
opened fire
letourneau was slammed to the ground
face-first face-first the impact so
severe he had thought he had broken his
nose
startled letourneau jumped up with his
car 15 pointing it toward the ak-47
gunfire that was near the front of the
team surprised that there were no nva
near him
laterno removed the rucksack to discover
that four ak-47 rounds had ripped
through the
23-pound prc 25.
he reached into an especially tailored
pocket on his fatigue shirt
which was sewn with vertical zippers one
on the left of his shirt one on the
right side
between the top and bottom of the
pockets on a shirt and pulled out his
urc
10 emergency radio and broadcast a
general alert for any aircraft in the
area
st virginia was declaring a prairie fire
emergency
then there was a sudden complete silence
eerie silent
amazed at the quietude letourneau walked
to childress who
asked him what he had done with the
prc25 letourneau explained that four
rounds had ripped through the radio and
that it was probably useless
get the [ __ ] radio children's yelled
what if it's working we leave it behind
for those [ __ ] to use
stunned laterno went back picked up the
rucksack and walked to childress who
grabbed the handset as nva troops began
firing at st
virginia and yelled into the radio we
have a [ __ ] prairie fire emergency
get us the [ __ ] out of here or i promise
we'll
i'll kick your ass all the way back to
saigon as the firefight raged on the
remainder of the team was lying down on
the ground
the firing at the nva y chill while
childress and letourneau
continued to argue while standing up
oblivious to the ak-47 rounds cracking
over their heads
later yelled back at childress it won't
work while pointing the prc
25 radio where the antenna had been shot
off no antenna
no combo letrono grabbed a spare whip
antenna and handed it to childress who
screwed into the radio
this time children screamed in the radio
we needed an ex-film now
i'm declaring a prairie fire emergency
is anyone out there
within a second or two there was a
response
calm down childress i realize you're
under fire said a covey rider
just at that moment several ak-47
ak-47s opened fire from the wood line
near the
log where letourneau had been
unceremoniously slammed onto his face
lap and cowboy returned fire covey rider
continued
we heard your team declare a prairie
prairie fire emergency on guard
frequency
and i've rallied the cavalry what's your
mark do you have an lz in sight
before children said a word into the
radio he turned to liturnu
and said see it works suppose we had
left it for the nva
never i say again never ever leave
behind a radio
as if to emphasize that point the nva
opened fire again as lap began
looking for an lz while moving the team
down the hill
away from the most concentrated nva
gunfire
cutting later no no slack childress
roared tell covey
we'll give him five we'll give him a fix
in five minutes we'll probably need
strings to get out of here i doubt we
can make it down to the valley where
kingby can pick us up without missing a
beat letourneau
who for the first time felt four burning
stings in his back repeated those words
to covey
while he and cowboy began providing
cover fire as the tail element of the
team
letourneau then laterno nodded to cowboy
who ignited several claymore mines that
the team had set out on its perimeter
those mines only slowed the nva for a
few seconds before the dust and debris
from the blast had settled nva soldiers
were moving
through it toward cowboy and lieterno
without saying a word the two men took
turns firing at the enemy while moving
downhill
rotating around each other cowboy would
fire several bursts from his car 15
and then reload as he reloaded
letourneau would open fire providing
covering fire for the team
during one short lull cowboy even
planted a claymore mine in the direction
of the advancing nva
and letourneau dug out another claymore
from his rucksack and placed a 10 second
delayed fuse on it
when the nva advanced again cowboy
ignited his claymore mine
the nva moved towards the team again
luterno ignited his fuse and ran down
the hill
with cowboy to catch up to their team
before they reached the team two b-40
anti-personnel rockets slammed into the
trees above them showering them with
shrapnel
a few more exploded as laterno and
cowboy moved down the hill
then the 10-second fuse ignited another
claymore it brought pet
precious time for the gun and run team
of letourneau and cowboy to turn
to cover ground and catch up to the
remainder of st virginia
as childress called in air strikes
laterno reflected on how surreal the
firefight had been
it wasn't anything like he had witnessed
on television or in any movie
instead of men charging each other and
killing each other in plain sight
here in triple canopy jungle he observed
green tracers from ak-47s first
or at the most an enemy hand or foot
and somehow the nva found firing lanes
where they could launch
shoulder-held b-40 anti-personnel
rockets
that slammed above them and around them
as they raced down the hill
again the voices of his special forces
instructors echoed in his mind
they had told the young aspiring green
berets at fort bragg that the nva was a
tough resilient opponent
many had fought against the japanese
during world war ii and against the
french driving
them from vietnam in 1954. the sounds of
king bees in the distance
and the crashing thunder of b-40 rockets
slamming into trees above his head
shook letourneau out of his moment of
introspection and turned his undivided
attention
to the crescendo of ak-47 fire from the
enemy
st virginia responded with a volley with
volley after volley of full and
semi-automatic gunfire while eternal and
cho
fired several m-79 rocket rounds toward
the densest section
of jungle where the ak-47 gunfire
was emanating through the gunfire
someone popped the smoke grenade which
brought the king bees closer to rt
virginia's location in the jungle
over the din of gunfire childress and
cowboy told everyone to put on their
swiss seats
and prepare for string extraction in
short order
a kingby was hovering over st virginia
more than 125 feet above the jungle
floor
letourneau cowboy cho and haun hooked
their d-rings into the old maguire rig
that hung from the end of the ropes and
shortly were being lifted out of the
jungle
as the quartet of recon men was being
lifted in the air
the nva released another salvo of ak-47
and b-40 rockets shrapnel from
the rockets hit them with varying
degrees of size and velocity
all of them were wounded it was during
these explosions that laterno realized
his car 15 and somehow become caught in
the rope above him
just far enough away that he couldn't
reach it he pulled out his m79 and
launched a grenade
toward the nva positions now all he
could see of the enemy were hundreds of
muzzle blasts from ak-47s
and green tracer rounds climbing upward
toward the quartet
of st virginia men before he could
reload his m-79 the king b began to move
away from the target area
surprising him because the men had not
cleared the jungle yet instead of
continuing to climb out of the target
moving straight up until the men cleared
the jungles triple canopy of
trees and vegetation the king bee was
moving away from the target area due to
the heavy enemy ground fire
in recent months at least two bees were
shot down during the string extractions
from hot targets
but these facts were unknown to luterno
at the time
shrapnel from b40 rockets exploded
around the st virginia men stringing
them with pieces of hot metal
stinging them with pieces of hot metal
further spooking the king b
crew luterno began to violently collide
with the tall jungle trees
feeling like a metal ball and a pinball
machine letourneau corooned off
several more trees at least one more b40
exploded in the treetops again
showering in with shrapnel a tree branch
hit literal from one side
and turned him upside down in his swiss
seat in his swiss seat
as the rope seat began to slip down his
hips letourneau remembered spider
telling how
a 1-0 from another team had recently
shot out of
been shot out of his swiss seat during a
rope extraction
another tree struck letourneau before he
was able to muster the surge of strength
and momentum to reach up and grab the
rope above him
as his body finally cleared the treetops
the only thing between him and certain
death below was the jungle floor 200
feet below
was the single piece of rope tied into
the king b
with one final urgent pull letourneau
was able to move himself
upright in the swiss seat as the king b
continued to climb higher into the sky
distancing itself from the fury of
exploding b-40s and ak-47
gunfire while gaining air speed
well there you go in and cowboy was
there for that and had
he was still recovering from the wounds
from october 5th
here he is around thanksgiving yeah so a
month and a half later
after your october 5th insanity
you're out there again almost healed
almost
big out the tree up uh
damn juan yeah uh
gnome and another one that
sent my village and they wanted me to go
with them
oh is that what it was they were from
your village and they wanted you to go
and help them
go to virginia yeah and then uh
by the way the new man lap uh
no the uh frenchman oh no because
was this the frenchman's first mission
is this cherry mission default mission
we don't just we don't trust how he's
learning
right so that's why we got to go strong
enough to protect him sure and by the
child
childhood it is very good perfect he he
perfect man but
he only won and then
frenchman hit the new guy we don't know
about him
but you know you know one zero had run
several missions
yes yes children they got an
experience either one
you know the frenchman like james strong
jim strike the first mission mm-hmm
the first mission is easy to go
that's why you know i'm volunteered to
go with the virginia
to take care of my my three friends
send my village and by the way that the
frenchman
hit a very new man baby son yes
baby we call him baby
[Laughter]
but he did okay but he's perfect yeah
but he good you're training good
did you train him how to kill the dogs i
don't know
i don't know i don't know but you know
we we very like the machine yes
when i shoot something he knew i ran out
of ammo
he covered me and when he run out the
machine
the ammo i cover him so
i i judge that he like at the
number two yes he number two
because the first time later on you know
i i know
he runs a lot of mission 13
yes i know about it i know he runs a lot
of mission but for sure
that's why he's so you know he's still
survival but that makes you all the more
amazing yeah i mean within
the third a month and a half only by
that
yeah you go from october 5th to this
mission as part of your six years inside
my scar hill not not really hill
almost you well you got new shrapnel too
yeah this new shrapnel wounds from that
but in order you know to
become like you and me right now
i cannot you know
leave you alone but i gotta go with you
sure because we close friend very close
friend
well that's that's what it's all about
and it's uh it's amazing to
be able to sit here and talk to you i
can't believe that i'm sitting here and
talking to you
uh i can't believe that you survived one
of those missions never mind
six years six years of those missions i
thought
yes normal no no
that's not just normal like somebody
else
no that's no one else we got pay
yeah right and then we got the bonus if
we do it the good thing
like if we have a uh pow do you remember
how much you got paid
one picture that 500 dollars i don't
know
how much is a piastre worth it depends
on what time of day it is maybe a dollar
so you go and do these missions for a
dollar you're a cheap date
it's like a five dollar five thousand
five dollar for a picture
yeah okay and then for a reason was
their vietnamese
currency we can learn a lot from the
song
like you remember sometimes we got a
radio small radio
right we get in the jungle we draw it
and then some special camera
and we throw in the jungle
and we learned a lot
we put in the sensors too yes and then
cameras and sensors
come around shenzhen and radio
you you you gotta ask me why
you throw the radio into the jungle
right right
i never knew about that so this is all
top secret so top secret even i didn't
even tell didn't know then you know it's
top secret
i know the system from the from the uh
from the department
but we don't know or whatever
do i have authority to speak in that
the radio we show in the jungle
this mean you gotta have a question
if the communists pick up the radio
who's the one that use it
that squad leader a platoon leader or a
company later and then blow up
no they not blow up inside the radio
they got us something
when they order anything airplane
no what's going on there you go
wow now we learn from them a lot
okay we talking to them we learn from we
learn we learn from them a lot
that's it or like at the
flashlight yes we told the jungle
nobody know and when we're training
to throw the flashlight in the jungle
the first question that they asked me
if you see the flashlight in the
do you pick it up
i'm going to say no you say no it you
know pasta tests
you should you should pick it up but the
nva might pick it up
yeah nva you got to pick it up oh
they're going to pick it up but i'm
saying i wouldn't
get him no because you'd have that thing
booby trapped or something because
you you thought you thought it it
important thing
just normal thing okay
the first question they asked you you
see the flashlight in the genre do you
pick it up you say
no that means something wrong with you
i say yes why not and i pick it up
and the second question what
what do you do with the flashlight when
you pick it up
turn it on turn it on
you fail the test
because it might in there how do you
know
when you turn it on it blows up
so many so many learning from
i i don't know how to tell you but you
know you did a pretty good job
yeah i gotta learn a lot i got to
learning a lot
okay team moving
three nva they follow you enemy phony
you the first question that
you want a three enemy debt or you want
a three
three enemy wounded
if i answered three m m that
you go home you cannot run recon anymore
you want pows i want a
three guy at this one guy that would it
why because
the team's still on the mission
they wanted another another nva got to
take care of them right
so that delay the time that they
followed the team
and if you get a pow you get a bonus
yeah
we bought a p asterisk for uh yes for a
pow yeah i don't know how many
pfw a lot yeah yeah
yeah we only got a hundred dollars so i
don't know what you would get i didn't
hear about that side of it
the reason that we got a bonus but now i
found that
bonus before that i don't know anything
i don't know just exactly just empty i
don't know
anything about it but we learn
we learn from him we learn from you we
learn from him
we learn a lot every every different guy
and we learn from you we
talk back and forth i learned from him
he
learned from me so we we sitted down we
show our experience like i told you
if i saw the enemy in the jungle
i kill him it easy but in order to
complete my
duty i gotta stay on the ground by
friday that's why i'm not qut i'm an
enemy i just stay there
and they they test you
how smart to handle the the thing happen
that's why i want to become you know the
recon team it's very difficult
but especially the first thing
protect this guy protect american guy
to first support joint
protect american right but we understand
that
we was recruited to refuel the american
came to the vietnam that's why
i can't tell you that i'm so lucky
i'm not good but you know just normal
just bring everything get normal better
better than for me
well you're definitely uh you're
definitely lucky and i can tell
from everything i've seen you're damn
good too that's
perfect perfect
yeah amazing it's just an amazing uh
story to sit here and and talk to you
and
and get this information and um
you know get other people to be able to
hear this story is just
it's awesome indeed do you got anything
else tilt
no this is it it's been a great ride and
thank you for bringing us together this
is really a special day
it's awesome you got anything else khan
thank you
to invite me to be here today but
our country situation right now
i am very sad
i can tell you my dad
gotta die by the sociology
my father did become unity
he the capitalist he not
very rich man but he middle guy
he made her in the vietnam
but the communism it know who that oh
please send a message to the people
don't trust the communism that's all i
can say that we're here we shaped it
but after the uh
the vote for president situation right
now
i'm sad
to let the
at my knowledge i don't know it true or
not
but another hand from the
communist room touched to the united
states of america
i've been here for ada for
32 years i never never get back to
country
i never visit the vietnam even i want to
go back there but
for the funerals yeah for the uh from
our friend is still back in the vietnam
but the vietnamese government
would let me get in
if you don't trust me i got a paperwork
in here
we trust you we do i work with the
uh general smith
who is the uh m.i.a
accounting his can he
he came in the hawaii smith
camp smith this is several years ago
right
now it i like it the uh
15 20 years ago okay i work with him
regarding about what powwows and mris
yes ken cry robinson
and honkaidy you know like the
helicopter destroyed
yes stride but they won't let me
get get there i ever met family
with the uh our friend
poking i'm i'm pick pick up the name the
king right now become a paul king yeah
poking
yes come on behave the poking it was
king and crying there were kia on alaska
when john allen escaped he you need
well i i can tell you i think one of the
reasons that you start seeing um
these things in america's people don't
understand communism
and they don't realize how evil it is
and so you coming on here and and
sharing your story and explaining what
you went through what your father went
through what your family went through
at the hands of the communists i can
assure you that there are
look there might be some americans that
don't understand but there are plenty of
americans that do understand and we will
never
let that evil form
of government control take over this
country
it will never happen
never i believe so i believe child but
in my shy i hear you know the
communists when they took over the uh
the u.s because they mess up
you know the water they messed up the
computer
vote for the president
he turned over to mr joe biden
i heard a lot of information so i scan
it
i want to buy both another boat now if i
got
it in order to happen you know i escaped
from
the united states you're not going to
need another boat to escape from united
states
we will make sure that doesn't happen
america
is stronger than one person and and our
roots are
deep and we will stay a free country and
because of men like you
we're we're able to be here today
absolutely
how would they mess up the country right
now the department of defense
metro expert the fire
and a lot of men get fired
they're under capable cover to another
country
why you said very strong
but we got to take care we got to be
careful with it
remember communism
control the people buy food
you don't have a food you can't do
anything
that's what they control the people in
china they can control the
north korea
you outside the con damn their country
you see hey hey look good the good the
good but
inside the country no good
eat no good they say you wanted
food you got to do it
they wanted water you do it
they want to fish one month for
two or three fish you gotta do it
i give you the paperwork to go buy
from the store it's not free like
here united states people
do you want anything you have everything
you can work for in there do you want
anything
you gotta listen and obey me
what to do trust me about the
the way it is you say very strong
country no
you see it it's no copy
how the government say you need to
take a match thinking about
listen why you know mr expert
he commander with the united states army
he got fired and another tree got fired
too
okay i'm looking back i i asked you the
question
american don't lose anything right but
why we still get out of vietnam
why we lose vietnam politics
politics because now
it's politic but with my experience
the opponent they can control you know
the hero guy like a jew like a man
and then we trust them we're gonna die
like at the the time it you know
mr obama you see the
do you see the picture marine in the
board
surrender with the what do you think
oh that was not a good situation at all
but why
why we still have a picture because the
people back in washington
like midterm they can't do anything
with a soldier we gotta do and we gotta
follow with the order
but they order us to come to die
so i'm not a politic guy i'm you know
retired man
72 years old i can't do anything
i can make any money but
i afraid of my children my grandchild
grow up living under combination
well that's a good point and i
appreciate that point you know i'm
sitting here sitting here saying oh
america's strong
but your point is we can't get arrogant
and think that it can't happen
to us we have to remain vigilant
all the time trust but verify indeed for
sure
well once again thank you for coming on
thank you for
sharing your stories you're always
welcome here
uh both you guys obviously are always
welcome here khan thanks for coming and
sharing your story
and and thank you more importantly for
your service
to your country to this country to
defend
freedom and democracy in the world
and thank you for taking care of your
big american brothers on the battlefield
and your vietnamese brothers as well and
and thank you for you and your family's
sacrifice on the altar of freedom amen
thank you amen
and with that tilt and cowboy
khan have left the building leaving
nothing but respect and admiration for
incredible service incredible men
and everything that they've gone to
everything they've gone through echo
charles you were sitting in the corner
yes we didn't have room for you at the
table that's okay
pretty pretty insane right yes
very much so yeah it's a it's a little
bit different when i'm like x
not excluded but x not in
on the table or detached detached yeah
i'm detaching even more
so yeah it is interesting you can sort
of
see and imagine really kind of what's
going on and what like everyone went
through and how it was
being like in a different culture you
know
and with military and stuff and then you
kind of compare it to all the people
that have
come on and shared their story yeah very
interesting
the crazy thing is though all those back
to back to back to back to back
years of doing these missions i mean the
sock guys could barely get out of there
alive
yeah and here's there's no getting out
okay so there's this part this might
seem kind of random but there's a part
of that i remembered where he
said that he could smell they could
smell he kind of opened up with that
yeah
yeah so and i was thinking about it
where it's like yeah i i see how that
could be really when you're so used to a
certain environment you can tell just a
little differences
like 100 percent man so uh
ever here's an exam like when you're at
home
right and if someone just came over
and just left you come in i don't even
know if you can smell them
but it's probably has something to do
with smell oh you can definitely smell
you know how you
put it this way that's what i thought to
you that you could smell them but i
can't smell something specific i know it
just smells
different you know that feeling so it it
almost does feel like a little bit of a
sense
you know so imagine that like or like
you know how like your your furniture
will be moved just a little bit
yeah and you walk in like like you know
i have a little home office whatever
and there's this couch and when i put it
in there
it is it's the perfect like i
painstakingly put it a certain distance
from the
there's a tv in there too and so
so when you're in your home office you
have a couch and a tv
yes just some other stuff that's cool
hey man i make videos got it you know
good good point anyway so one time i was
fixing something underneath the couch
and i just you know i had to
apparently move it just a little bit and
just didn't think about it and then when
i
walked in like later that night or
whatever i was like immediately felt it
it was
it was off by like literally one inch
literally
and i could feel it i looked at it it
was like threw me off you know so that's
kind of the kind of stuff he was
thinking
yeah and those guys growing up in the
jungle
they grow up in the jungle yeah and so
they're just a hundred percent in tune
with it
and then you got the big gringos coming
in
you know and until he kept calling
himself a city slicker
amazing amazing guys well when i hear
stories like that it certainly makes me
feel like
like we can step up our game like i can
definitely step up my game
like i can do better do better
always training like cowboys oh man
cowboys and you know what i don't know
if we captured it because we were
talking before we pressed record
but he started getting really into
training you know just like how
how well they trained yeah and he did
mention it a bunch you know he did
mention a bunch but he
he gave kind of the foundational part
about training before we pressed record
you know like the foundational how much
it meant so he kept saying it and he
reiterated it especially at the end you
know he was reiterating it but
yeah it's no doubt you always gotta
train always gotta be prepared
you never know you never know what's
going to happen you train harder
yeah kind of applies to everything too
even if you don't necessarily want to
think of it in terms of like oh there's
an
enemy out there you know literally
or even figuratively if you if you don't
necessarily want to think about
that part of it all the time it's it has
to do with capability
because the enemy that can mean anything
if you want to go metaphoric
i'm i'm you're you're preaching the
wrong guy here i'm down with
[Music]
well let's face it if you have a
let's say you're bringing home a you
know those big water jugs five gallon
water jugs yeah you put in a water
cooler or whatever let's say you bring
some of those home
okay and let's say you don't have a lift
gate on your truck or you
you just have a car you have a car you
put it's in the back seat
and now you got to reach in there and
you got to grab it at this awkward angle
see him saying that in and of itself
could be an enemy yeah
never mind the nva storming your
position
yeah more important it could be the
water bottle this is the scenario the
chance of an
nva storming your position today a
little bit lower than you grabbing a
water
jug maybe i don't know i don't know
everyone's different i get it
nonetheless point still remains look
we're trying to keep ourselves capable
we're trying to train we want to keep
training
regardless of how often you are
what's performing perform we'll call it
a performance well you are actually
are performing all the time it's another
way of thinking of things and performing
and training all the time because you
gotta learn from your performance right
it's insane
it's like yeah those deals yeah
anyway all right we're doing it um
through training comes
beatings comes breakdowns
more or less most of the time actually
all the time sometimes i just gotta
leave you to figure it out
like those statements right there i can
tell you're
maybe you threw it out there as if you'd
get some support no but it didn't come
i do do that sometimes but this is not
one of those times
anyway when we build ourselves back up
the benefits of training
sometimes we get little nagging things
in our joints or other places whatever
we don't ever worry about that kind of
stuff so
jaco has joint warfare super krill oil
these things these are
supplements supplementation for your
joints okay so the whole line is called
jackal fuel so with that geofeel for
your joints
has like i said joint warfare super
crude oil we also have for your brain
and body by the way is a
i don't want to call it a product even
though it is a product
okay i'm going to call it a product we
have a product
don't call it a product all right see
you okay you feel me then uh
what yeah we have a thing called
substance discipline right so it's
disciplined you can take this
form of supplementation in actually in a
few forms so you got
the powdered version mix it with water
that's what i had to do today
yes sir pill don't mix it with water
just swallow it
swallow it maybe with some water or
whatever quick hitter
or in the cans kind of like an energy
drink
if you will except for one that's
literally good for you
actually healthy actually healthy yeah
so yes
real energy yes not fit you know what
else gives you energy
cocaine apparently right
uh that's what i heard from cocaine
gives you energy makes you feel like
hey i'm gonna go and work hard right now
energetic or
crystal methamphetamine apparently that
gives you energy too
a little bit different but yeah no you
don't go around saying hey you should oh
you need some energy
do some cocaine right we're not doing
that it's unhealthy it's bad for you
we'll say it's unhealthy yeah
sure there's other the category that you
just used
quote energy drinks which are in the
same realm
potentially not quite but okay maybe not
quite
i understand what you're saying no
philly yes so yeah
a lot of times when energy drink you're
like hey let's let's drink all
like two three four five energy drinks
you're gonna be like
i don't know about all that shouldn't we
not be drinking energy drinks it's kind
of you have that feeling a lot of
yes i'm saying but the splint go in the
can
may even actually might even kind of
look like an energy drink it doesn't
it's just not like that yeah it's this
is actual healthy things
real energy because that's what i was
going to say because cocaine that's not
real energy well it depends on when you
what you mean by
real and it depends on what you mean by
energy okay i mean
in the spirit we'll have to get some uh
some somebody with some expertise and
cocaine in here to discuss
and energy and energy nonetheless you
know what i'm saying healthy energy
don't do cocaine yes instead correct try
discipline go in a can
all the sick none of the negative
benefits
no dude do you remember what i was no
not all those things check it out i
brought
i was on theo vaughn's podcast sure hell
yeah and he was drinking
uh discipline go and he said something
really funny he's
and he just kind of slid under the radar
comment
but he said something comparing it to
cocaine and he said actually i think i'm
going back on a cocaine
i think that's what's in my brain right
now yeah that's weird because i don't
like i don't pound well i have i won't
like drink the whole thing super fast
but then
actually that's not true i have but when
you drink it super fast then yeah i
think you'll get
like a little jolt yeah well super fast
meaning
how long when you down it like in three
four or less hits oh that's a that's
definitely you down you know that one
for yeah oh yeah for sure
but no if i do if i drink like two over
the course of a podcast like i will not
feel like
what i imagine cocaine feels like yeah
i've never done cocaine yeah
me neither nonetheless it's not cocaine
it's good for you yeah
it's a crystal methamphetamine and
cocaine are not good for you you're
unhealthy yes
jacqueline go is good for you okay
i think that's what we're trying to say
over here all right yes it's true
also speaking of good for you uh vitamin
d3
fuel very good for you keep you
healthy immune system strong
also immune system strong stuff cold war
it's another one so boom you got the
whole gambit yeah
what gambit right that's correct that's
good good usage
approved yeah yeah um of stuff you know
for that kind of stuff you don't want to
worry about see i'm saying yeah plus we
got mulk we got warrior kid milk which
is protein that tastes good
plus we got jocko white tea and plus all
the stuff that we're talking about you
can get it at origenmaine.com or you can
get it at the vitamin shop
or you can get it
in florida right now and it looks like
very soon wawa all over the east coast
it looks like we're heading in that
direction
yeah so everyone that's been oh by the
way everyone that in florida
has been going out and basically getting
after it clearing shelves
thank you thank you we're heading in the
right direction
beach hat the beach head is
under the process of being secured at
this time which we feel good about
yes yeah um also yes so you mentioned
orange main.com
at or back to our gmail.com this is what
you where you can get
american-made stuff
including but not limited to jiu-jitsu
rash guards
some hoodies on there some joggers on
there some shorts on there which i don't
haven't been talking about but they're
aside from board shorts they're the only
shorts
i wear but you normally wear board
shorts
very often oh yes i do oh in the on the
mats of justice mass of justice
uh workout um
uh every single day in hawaii okay yeah
it's either
church or that straight up got it check
i jumped the
proverbial gun on that one oh good hey
we're all here training learning
also because i only see you in the
origin shorts
the shark fin short that's the only
shorts i see you in because
unless we're on the maps right
yeah of justice yep that's true
also at origin main still in our gemaine
jeans american-made denim from the from
the
cotton grown to make the fabric to make
the denim to make the jeans all made in
america yep
by the way um also boots on there delta
jeans are back in the game
yeah delta c i'm wearing them right now
yeah i saw that yeah i saw that that's
right and i saw you you kind of like
gave me a you grabbed the material and
kind of pulled it
right what was your assessment yeah yeah
well my assessment was that they have
some give some legitimate
give to them and it i just reflected on
the fact that i don't have any
i'm really sorry but the new delta genes
are freaking
and they are a little bit new so we had
the original
delta genes and then during kovid we
re-engineered some stuff we got some
denim that we liked even more
what is it the cup the cut hell yeah
yeah they're just they're just freaking
awesome now
so um were they always dark like that
dark
you probably see i my og pair of deltas
that i just wore i wear them all the
time and so they they're like jeans
because they fade a little bit they fade
as time goes on
so the pair that you're seeing right now
are basically brand new gotcha
no i i like the dark denim yeah well
they're good it will fade over time
right on cool yeah so what do you mean
calm also boots i forgot that don't
forget about booze same deal
yeah works of art art for you from work
for your feet free feet made in america
all good
also chocolate stores called jacko store
this is where you can get discipline
equals
freedom shirts hats hoodies lightweight
and heavyweight by the way
um some women's stuff on there some
beanies some rash guards
some soap some soap some water your kids
soap where you could soak jack of soap
trooper soap
yeah killer soap by the way all the
stuff that we're talking about
it if you want to support the podcast
you want to provide some level of
support this stuff helps us out
you know that way that way we don't have
to get sponsors
yeah yeah there's that because look this
might be annoying which i'm sure it is
oh this whole thing right no but okay
maybe not for you
but for a lot of people this might be
super annoying but the cool thing is you
don't have to listen to it
we didn't put it in the middle of you
know
cut off cowboy and just start hey here's
a word from
uh whatever we're not doing that yeah
that is so we appreciate it
when you get if you you look we need
stuff and i'm not a big
what's the what's the minute i will look
we all want to be a minimalist
right we want to be a minimalist don't
want to buy a bunch of stuff but there's
stuff that you do need
for instance do you need a ghee yes you
do do you need a pair of jeans
yes you do do you need a t-shirt yes you
do
do you need food yes you do do you need
supplementation
yes you like all these we're just making
stuff that you need so if you need it
you can get it from us it helps out the
podcast it provides a little bit of that
support
so yeah it's like a win-win it helps
everything yeah
you could go to like a local store
and buy right yeah you could a pair of
jeans that were made in china
you could do that i mean you you are
allowed to
yeah but it's not really it's not really
let's face it it's not really what you
want to do no it's very questionable for
sure
questionable behavior anyways speaking
of this podcast you can oh wait wait
wait wait wait no no okay speaking of
subscribing
actually back to the job okay
so we have a t-shirt club we'll call it
a subscription
scenario where you get a like a
how should i say like a unique unique i
guess
yeah i guess that's a given anyway you
get a shirt every month that's kind of
more like
it's different but it's still in the
game on the path
etcetera anyway go to jackalstore.com
and you can
check them out see if you like that one
but yeah that's a cool little thing
people
been doing that we offer it's pretty
cool and then if you get a t-shirt from
this
thing you can't get it anywhere else
no you can't even really get it on the
store
really if they're only for like you'll
see like when you see kind of the
examples of someone you'll be like okay
this kind of makes sense they're fun
and they're you know so yeah we have
there's always all kinds of cool ideas
that come in
for shirts for this for that but we
can't just execute them all
no they will they're varying level scale
yeah so
you know we're doing a lot of those on
an exclusive scale
kind of yeah not what i mean kind of i
don't know
i don't know what you meant by scale
that's why on an exclusive scale meaning
we're not doing it
on a mass scale hey everyone that wants
one of these no it's on a more exclusive
scale like oh we don't have to make
whatever however me whatever the number
of t-shirts is yes because we don't know
what
someone's going to order yeah yeah
you're correct if they're in the game
then we know it and you get a shirt that
looks cool
that has more layers there are many
layers all
infused in that situation nonetheless
yes draculastore.com
also like jocko indicated you can
subscribe to this podcast
on wherever you subscribe to the podcast
there you go boom and don't forget about
the unraveling podcast
that that i i also record and don't
forget about the grounded podcast which
we are supposed to record but we haven't
recorded a lot of
don't forget about the warrior kid
podcast which
hopefully during thanksgiving when some
people
don't have to work i'll be able to slip
in there and record some
warrior kid podcasts so we're gonna work
on that one don't forget about we have a
youtube
channel a youtube channel and this is
where
the creative mind of echo trolls
manifests itself
via explosions tanks
airplanes and if you want to watch a
video that's 30 seconds long that has a
lot of stuff blown up go there
if you also want to watch a video that's
four hours long with nothing blowing up
also go there yeah boom yes that is true
youtube channel all good official by the
way
also psychological warfare if you don't
know what that is
it's an album audio album with tracks of
jocko telling you
explaining to you how to get past your
moments of weakness
in the event of them arising which
they do from time to time let's face it
but yeah have draco there just tell you
hey
you shouldn't do this you should do this
see this thing you're thinking about
doing
that you won't want to have done
don't do that don't do that thing jocko
version of that it's actually really
helpful
my opinion uh we also have a visual
version of that
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer making
all kinds of cool stuff
there's a bunch of books what books did
we cover today well we're talking about
sog
so if you're going to jump in a sog you
can get across the fence on the ground
and saga chronicles
by john striker meyer and then you can
also get whiskey tango foxtrot
by lynn black you need about face by
david hackworth there's a new version
now a re-release
that i wrote the forward to there's
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual there's the code the protocols
and the evaluations there's this freedom
field manual there's a brand new version
of that out
that's that's a good go-to for that
christmas scenario
yes it is the holiday scenario
check that one out way the warrior kid 4
field manual is also i think it's live
right now
yeah it's live way the warrior could
four field minutes here's the thing on
all these
from what i understand intel
there's gonna be a shortage of aircraft
trucks and laborers drivers pilots
during christmas because everything is
going to be shipped
so if you want to get any of this stuff
even though i know you we're all trying
to be minimalist but kids need a
freaking book to read
so get them away the warrior kid four
field mail way to work kid one two and
three
mikey and the dragons and then extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
i have a leadership consultancy called
echelon front where we solve problems
through leadership you can go to
salonfront.com for that
we have ef online which is
where we do leadership training online
interactive so you can go check that out
efonline.com we got the muster in dallas
texas
you can come check that out in
extremeownership.com
we have ef overwatch which is executive
leadership
for your company that understands the
principles that we talk about
if you want to help service members
active and retired
their families gold star families if you
want to help out
veterans and if you want to help out
american service
men and women then check out mark lee's
mom mama lee
she has a charity organization you can
go and donate or get involved at
america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you like to torment yourself
well you can do so with more of my
protracted pronouncements or maybe
some more of echo's hyped up hypotheses
you can find us on the interweb on
twitter on instagram
and just so echo knows because he only
refers to instagram as
the gram and also on facebook echo's
addict with charles and i'm at jocko
willing and it should
more importantly be known that john
striker meyer is on instagram
at j striker meyer and once again
thanks to tilt and cowboy for their
incredibly heroic
we need a new word beyond heroic for
their service
to america and freedom
we will not forget
the sacrifice or the legacy of these
warriors
and thanks to all the warriors all over
the world in the army
navy air force marines coast guard
and also to those foreign nationals that
we
fight alongside
thank you for defending freedom and
the same to police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all
first responders thanks for keeping us
safe here at home
and to everyone else out there i've got
one thing
to say
until next time this is echo and jocko
out